TO ORDER COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE
MEDINA CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY ON
HIGHER EDUCATION WELCOME TO THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WHETHER YOU ARE HERE IN PERSON
OR WATCHING VIRTUALLY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. AND
THE- FIRST. ITEM OF BUSINESS IS
TO WISH OF MY COMMITTEE STAFF.
ELLEN A HAPPY BIRTHDAY TODAY.
AND TO WELCOME HER PARENTS AND
GRANDMOTHER THIS IS CERVANTES
HERE WITH US IN THE HEARING
THIS AFTERNOON WELCOME. SO I'D
LIKE TO THE TO NOTE A SLIGHT
CHANGE ON THE AGENDA INSTEAD OF
DOCTOR GONZALEZ THE ACTING
CHANCELLOR WILL BE HEARING FROM
DAVID O'BRIEN THE VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS WILL BE REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN OUR FIRST PANEL.
PLEASE NOTE THAT ALL MATERIALS
FOR THE HEARING TODAY CAN BE
ACCESSED ONLINE. AT H. T. T. P.
OUR- IT'S DOUBLES LASH AHEAD
ASSEMBLY DOT CALIFORNIA DOT
GOVERNMENT HEARINGS. I ALSO
LIKE TO EXTEND SPECIAL THANK
YOU TO ALL THE STAFF THAT HAVE
MADE- THIS HEARING POSSIBLE
THIS FALL AND I WILL GO OVER
SOME OF THE KEY ELEMENTS OF THE
STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S OVERSIGHT
HERE. PLEASE NOTE THAT MASTER
REQUIRED TO BE WORN AT ALL
TIMES BY EVERYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO. PLEASE BE SURE TO WEAR
YOUR MASK IN THE APPROPRIATE
WAY WITH YOUR MOUTH AND NOSE
FULLY COVERED. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS AS FOR
WITNESSES TESTIMONY TODAY. IN
THE HEARING ROOM OR BY
TELEPHONE. WHEN WE REACH THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF THE
AGENDA I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE ROOM TO PLEASE APPROACH THE
MIKE. ONE PERSON AT A TIME AND
POLICEMEN PAYING SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AS YOU MOVE AROUND
THE ROOM. I WOULD ALSO ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOMS ONCE YOU FINISH
TESTIFYING A RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. WE WILL ALSO BE USEDIN
AN AT&T MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH WITNESSES
CAN TESTIFY ON THE TOPIC
PRESENTED TODAY THERE MIGHT BE
A SLIGHT DELAY. SO I ASK THAT
ALL INVOLVED REMAIN PATIENT.
THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE. FOUR TWO-
TO. CAN FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON THE TV OR MONITOR SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE BE SURE TO
MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING. WITNESSES WHO ARE
UNABLE TO PHYSICALLY ATTEND THE
HEARING TODAY CAN SUBMIT
WRITTEN COMMENTS VIA THE
LEGISLATIVE PORTAL. PLEASE NOTE
THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
TRANSMITTERS COMMITTED IS
CONSIDERED A PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAY BE READ INTO THE RECORD.
FOR PANELISTS. THE MAJORITY OF
THE PANELISTS HAVE ELECTED TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON. SOME OF OUR
PANELS OF ELECTED JUST
TESTIFIED REMOTELY AND WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE.
FROM THE HEARING ROOM AND ASK
QUESTIONS. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS DURING THIS HEARING
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION
AT NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
THREE NINE SIX ZERO AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WITH
THE HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS STATED I
HAVE A FEW OPENING REMARKS. A
YEAR AGO THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE CONVENED A HEARING TO
DISCUSS THE IMPACT OF COVERT
NINETEEN ON POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. AT THE TIME OF THE
HEARING THE STATE WAS IT
HEARING TO STRICT STAY AT HOME
ORDER AND THE BUDGETARY OUTLOOK
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION WAS GRAHAM.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE A YEAR MAKES
AFTER A YEAR AND A HALF OF
REMOTE OR DISTANCE LEARNING.
STUDENTS AND FACULTY OF RETURN
TO CAMPUS AND THE STATE HAS
MADE SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
INVESTMENT IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
DESPITE THE SUCCESSFUL RETURN
TO CAMPUS THE IMPACTS IMPACTS
OF COVERT NINETEEN CONTINUE TO
REVERBERATE THROUGHOUT HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. WELL
THE PANDEMIC HAS PRODUCED
UNIQUE CHALLENGES FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION IN MITIGATING NATION
WIDE ENROLLMENT LOSS LEARNING
LAS AND WIDESPREAD WORK FORCED
RESIGNATIONS THE PANDEMIC HAS
ALSO PROVIDED AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION TO
QUESTION THE CONVENTIONAL NORMS
OF HOW EDUCATION IS PROIDED.
THIS HEARING WILL ALLOW US TO
GAIN MORE UNDERSTANDING AND
AWARENESS OF THE VARIETY OF
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES THAT
HIGHER EDUCATION IS FACING AND
WILL HOPEFULLY PROVIDE US
pEDUCATION IS ANSWERING THE
QUESTION. HOW DO WE RECOVER
WITH EQUITY. I'LL BE LISTENING
CLOSELY TO ALL THE PANELISTS I
KNOW THE DUE TO SAFETY
PROTOCOLS WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO INCLUDE EVERYONE THAT WE
WOULD UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY HAVE
INCLUDED AS A PANELIST. BUT
WILL ALSO LISTEN FOR THOSE THAT
WAS SPEAK DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. SO OUR FIRST- PANEL
NORMALIZING THE RETURN TO
CAMPUS THE SEGMENT'S RESPONSE
TO SAFETY HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
CONCERNS. IN THE POST PANDEMIC
ERROR. THIRTEEN WELCOME DR
MICHAEL BROWN PROVOST AND
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
ACADEMIC AFFAIRS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WILL
BE TESTIFYING VIA WEBEX DR
SOVIET ALBERT EXECUTIVE VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR ACADEMIC AND
STUDENT AFFAIRS FOR CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. DAVID O'BRIEN
THE VICE CHANCELLOR
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALEX GRAVES VICE PRESIDENT FOR
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND-
UNIVERSITIES. AND I DON'T KNOW
THE WILL BEGIN WILL BEGIN. VIA
WEBEX. I START TO MEDINA YOU
YOU MAY BEGIN- ARCADE THANK YOU
AND- NUMBER EIGHT THANK YOU FOR
IN FORM VI<c.cyan> MEDIA. AND ALL</c>
OF US TO SPEAK BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
DO SO THANK YOU AND- AND HI
GREETINGS TO THE HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE- ASSEMBLY HIGHER
IT COMMITTEE I WAS ASKED TO
SPEAK JUST IN BRIEF ABOUT- YOU
KNOW SOME OF OUR- PROCEDURES
FOR. SAFELY RETURNING TO IN
CAMPUS ACTIVITY AND AN IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION I WAS ALSO
ASKED TO SPEAK. IN BRIEF ABOUT.
HI GOOD MORNING IMPACTS ON OUR
STUDENTS AND HOW THOSE CAN ARE
BEING AND CAN BE. ADDRESSED I
WAS ALSO ASKED TO ADDRESS- IF
THERE WERE ISSUES OF-
ENROLLMENT LAWSON- AND- AND
WHAT IS THE PICTURE THERE AND
CERTAINLY I WAS ASKED AS YOU
MENTIONED CHAIR MEDINA OUT
ABOUT- THE GOING FORWARD HOW DO
WE RECOVER WITH WITH EQUITY SO
I'LL TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE IN
BRIEF BUT I'M CERTAINLY
AVAILABLE. FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT THEY THAT YOU
WOULD COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE. IN
BRIEF- ALL CAMPUSES HAVE
RETURNED TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION OF COURSE OUR
SEMESTER CAMPUSES ARE RETURNED
TO THAT STATUS EARLY IN IN
AUGUST AND- AND THE OTHERS IN
SEPTEMBER FOR MOST OF OUR
CAMPUSES THAT IS MEANT ROUGHLY
ABOUT YEAH- 85% OF THE COURSES
ARE IN PERSON BUT THAT MEANS. A
SIGNIFICANT OUR PORCH ABOUT 15%
R. OUR- AND REMOTE. ONLINE
HYBRID. OUR CAMP WILL. AT THE
FIVE OF COURSE- LOCAL- AND
COUNTY HEALTH CARE GUIDANCE. WE
ALSO HAD IN THE UC SYSTEM OUT A
VACCINE- POLICY MANDATE SO WITH
FEW EXCEPTIONS. ARE ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE GOING TO
BE ON CAMPUS HAD TO BE
VACCINATED AND THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR OF OUR A
RETURNED. TO CAMPUS SAFELY-
PROTOCOL UP. KICK OUT ALL
INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO FURNISH
PROOF OF THAT VACCINATION AND
IF THE WORK NOT GOING TO BE
FAXED A DEBT TO HAVE APPROVED
THE EXCEPTION. AND I AND WHICH
WERE WERE VERY FEW OUT WE HAD
AN AIM FOR ABOUT 9090% OF THOSE
ON CAMPUS IS BEING VACCINATED
AND ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
MET AND EXCEEDED THAT. ARE
THERE ARE ALL WHEN YOU'RE IN IN
PERSON INDOORS YOU HAVE TO BE
MASKED AND ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES
HAVE PROTOCOLS FOR MANAGING
MASS MIGRATIONS TO AND FROM
CAMPUS WHICH IS A SENSITIVE
TIME FOR- FACT- FOR OUR VIRUS
TRANSMISSION. SO SO THEY HAD TO
BE TESTED BEFORE TO KMART YEAH.
THEY HAD. TO HAVE SOME A
SEQUESTERING- TO SEE IF
EVERYTHING WAS OKAY. AND AND
YOU THEY ARE- CHAU DEPOSIT THEY
HAD TO BE ISOLATED- ARE IS PART.
FOR THOSE WHO- HAD THE FEW
EXCEPTIONS THAT WERE GRANTED
THEIR TO SUBMIT TO A
SYMPTOMATIC PERIODIC TESTING.
WE YOU KNOW THIS THIS VIRUS IS
OPPORTUNISTIC. AND IT LOOKS FOR
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO BREAK
THROUGH AND RIGHT NOW THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE WE HAVE
BECAUSE THINGS HAVE BEEN GOING
VERY WELL ON OUR CAMPUSES-
WE'VE BEEN CONCERNED FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING. ABOUT AREN'T
AREN'T NOT ONLY THE SAFETY OF
FOLKS ON OUR CAMPUSES BUT THE
SAFETY OF OUR SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES WE DIDN'T WANT TO
BE THE SOURCE OF- OF- OF
INFECTION TO ARE SURROUNDED
COMMITTEE MUNITY SAID WE HAVE
FOUND THAT FROM THE BEGINNING
THROUGH THE LEADERSHIP OF
PRESIDENT DRAKE. AND HIS TEAM-
THAT ARE INFECTION RATES ON
CAMPUS OUR OUR OUR WHOLE ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE BELOW THAT OF OUR
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES AT
LEAST- HI AND AS SOME OF YOU
MAY KNOW WHAT THE SEPTEMBER
REGENTS- WE HAD A PRESENTATION
BY UC BERKELEY AND UC MERCED.
ABOUT HOW- HOW THINGS HAVE BEEN
GOING UNDER CAMPUS EVERYBODY
WAS HESITANT. RETURNING TO
CAMPUS NO ONE WANTED ADD THAT
TO NOT GO WELL TO STUDENTS IN
PARTICULAR AND I MUST SAY-
THINGS HAVE GONE WELL THERE'S
YEAH HI AND OX AND EVERYBODY IS
COMPLYING WITH THE PROTOCOLS.
NOW REGARDING LEARNING- HI IT
CHAIR MEDINA I I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AT THE CONCERNS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS RAISED
UP LEARNING IS HIGHLY DEPENDENT
ON LEARNING CONTEXT. AND THE
SHIFT TO PEOPLE'S HOME
ENVIRONMENT WAS AN EVENLY
EXPERIENCED BY OUR STUDENTS NOT
EVERYBODY'S HOME ENVIRONMENT
COULD BE ADAPTED TO OUR AND
EFFECTIVE AND CONDUCIVE.
ENVIRONMENTS FOR OPTIMAL
LEARNING AND- AND MANY OF US
KNOW ALSO THAT WE'RE. HAVING ON
OUR CAMPUS NOW- FOR EXAMPLE AS-
FOLKS THAT ARE ARE BEING ON THE
K. FOR TO TIME. AND OUR AND
SOME OF OUR FRESHMEN HAD FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS HAVE NOT
BEEN. EXPERIENCE IN PERSON
MONEY ARE TRANSFER STUDENTS I
HAVEN'T EXPERIENCED IN PERSON
LEARNING SO IT'S AN ADJUSTMENT.
PERIOD- AND OUR END WE WERE IN
A GLOBAL. AND SOAK EVEN THOUGH
THERE WAS CONTINUITY OF
LEARNING. THE ROUTE THE SAME
PROCESSES WORK THE SECOND. IN
REMOTE SO WE'RE ALL HAVING TO
ADJUST TO NEW REALITIES OF
BEING ON CAMPUS AND OUR
CAMPUSES ARE LEARNING FROM EVEN
AS THEY HAVE PREPARED TO DEAL
WITH THAT- ALL RIGHT ATTY AND I
WILL SAY THAT- BECAUSE OF THE
LEARNING LOSSES- IN LATER HIGH
SCHOOL- ARE WE HAVE HAD TO AN
APPROPRIATELY HAD BRIDGE
PROGRAMS DURING THE SUMMER WE
THINK THOSE WERE. VERY
IMPORTANT TO MITIGATE THOSE
LEARNING LOSSES WE DO THINK
ADAM AT THAT ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTS OUR ONGOING WILL BE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT STUDENT
ACADEMIC- AS SUCCESS ON OUR
CAMPUSES IN TRANSITION TO OUR
CAMPUS WE DO WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT- AS PART OF OUR EFFORTS TO
CONTAIN TO INVEST IN CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS THAT WE HAVE TO.
KEEP VIGILANT ABOUT THAT INVEST
EVEN MORE SO- AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THE HELP OF FIVE OF
OUR OUR LEGISLATURE IN AND
RECOGNIZING THOSE NEEDS AND
HELPING US TO ADDRESS THEM FROM
A STUDENT SENATE OUR POINT OF
VIEW- A COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS-
AND MENTION THE END I AM- IN
TERMS OF. ENROLLMENT LOSS WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT WE ARE
COLLECTING- DATA ON THAT RIGHT
NOW BY THE END OF NOVEMBER WILL
ACTUALLY KNOW IF THERE WAS ANY
LOSS IN ROME BUT WE EXPECT THAT
THAT THAT'S NOT THE CASE. BUT
ARE YOU WILL ALSO NOTE THAT WE
HAD RECORD- ADMISSIONS ARE BOTH
IN TERMS OF. THE OVERALL SIZE
OF THOSE ADMISSIONS THE NUMBER
CALIFORNIA- STUDENTS THAT WERE
ADMITTED TO THE NUMBER TRANSFER
STUDENTS THAT WERE MADE AT THE
RECORD NUMBER OF ARE YOU AROUND
STUDENTS THAT WERE ADMITTED OUT
4403% OF OUR- AND MINUTE
CLASSES WERE- WERE YOU ARE THEM
AND- R. AND FIRSTHAND IN PAL
THAT. FOR US BOTH IN TERMS OF
PERCENT AND NUMBERS WERE WERE
RE. IN AND WE ARE PROUD OF THAT.
AT THE SAME TIME WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE STUDENTS
HAVE AN EXCELLENT. AND
APPROPRIATE EXPERIENCE OUT ON
OUR CAMPUSES SO WELL WE'RE
CHALLENGED TO BE INCLUSIVE OUR
IN OUR PEDAGOGY INCLUSIVE YEAH-
IN OUR SUPPORT- AND MAKE SURE
THAT- THAT WE DON'T LOSE THOSE
GAMES- SOME. ARE OTHER THINGS I
WILL SAY- WE ARE IN ACTIVE
LEARNING ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF
THIS I'M PRESIDENT. AND I WE'D
WE HAVE LEARNED IN BELIEVE THAT
SUMMER. AND SUMMER COURSE WORK
HAS BEEN VERY IMPORTANT-
STUDENTS SEEM TO LOOK. AT LEAST
WHEN WE WERE IN A REMOTE AREA-
SEEM TO REALLY APPRECIATE IT
BEING ABLE TO MAINTAIN AND
ADVANCE THEIR THEIR EDUCATION
THROUGH SUMMER AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT- WE
APPRECIATE OUR BY THE WAY I
WANT TO MENTION DURING THE
PANDEMIC- HI. THAT THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IN BASIC NEEDS FOR
OUR STUDENTS AND NOT JUST OUR
STUDENTS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ACCOUNTS THE STUDENTS
ARE HAS BEEN OF GREAT HELP AND
SOLD LET ME THANK. YOU CHAIRMAN
THIS COMMITTEE- AT THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND SONG FOR THAT
KIND OF SUPPORT AND INVESTMENT-
HI LET ME SAY THAT AS WE THINK
ABOUT RECOVERY WE HAVE TO AND I
AM SO APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S FOCUS HERE WE HAVE
TO RECOVER WITH WITH AN EQUITY
MINDSET. ACT IN MY VIEW A CHAIR
MEDINA- EDUCATIONAL EQUITY IS
ONE OF THE IMPEATIVES OF OUR
TIME- AND SO HOW DO WE BEST
ENSURE. INCLUSIVE ACCESS. TO
BAKE IT TO EXCELLENCE IN
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITY THAT IS
OUR CHALLENGE AND ACT IN
EQUITY. IS CHEAP. EQUITY COSTS.
AND THAT MEANS HAVE TO BE
FOCUSED ON IT FOCUSED ON THE
WITH INTENTIONALITY AND BRING
TO NOT ONLY DIRECT VISION BUT
THE RIGHT WILL AND RESOURCES TO
IT HIMSELF- ARE YOU WILL KNOW
THAT WE ARE INVESTED AND ARE
YOU SEE FOUR OUT. OF AT TWENTY
THIRTY FRAMEWORK- WHICH IS
FOCUSED ON EQUITY BOTH IN TERMS
OF. THE STUDENTS WE HAVE MET
THE DEGREES THAT WERE FOCUSED
ON- AND GENERATING FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE STATE CLOSING
THE GRADUATION GAP FOR PALE
FIRST CHEN AND- AND-
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS AND
WE'RE INVESTING. IN
DIVERSIFYING AND I BY THE WAY I
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEE
SUPPORT OF THIS ON DIVERSIFYING
OUR PROFESSORIAL WE'RE MAKING
GAINS HERE- BUT NOW'S NOT THE
TIME TO LET AT NILES THE TIME
TO ACTUALLY REINVEST IN THAT WE
DO HAVE A GENERATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY THERE. AND OUR
FACULTY STAFF ARE DIVERSE THE
FINE AND THAT IS IMPROVING AND
THAT IS GOOD WE GOT TO SUSTAIN
IT WE'VE GOT WE APPRECIATE THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT IN STATE
THAT. BECAUSE OUT OUR EARLY OUT
REACH OUT EARLY PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR K. TWELVE. BROTHERS IN
IN EIGHT A. G. QUALITY EIGHT GB
AND TAUGHT- ARE ENOUGH IN OUR
TRANSFER TOOLS ARE BETTER OUT%
REACH TO A BROADER RANGE OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO THAT
THEY'RE MORE REPRESENTED IN OUR
UC SYSTEM. THESE ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE MUST BE FOCUSED ON EVEN
AS WE DO THINGS LIKE HOW WE'VE
PARTNERED WITH OUR STUDENT
ASSOCIATION ON DOUBLING THE
PAL. AND OUR PRESIDENT IS VERY
INVESTED. IN CREATING A DEBT
FREE PATHWAY OF FOUR OUT FOR
QUALIFYING STUDENTS AND SO THAT
WE ARE ABLE- ADDED TO F. AND
LUMINATE A BARRIER OR CHALLENGE
FOR STUDENTS ONCE THEY GRADUATE
SO I HOPE I DIDN'T GO TOO MUCH
OVER TIME- BUT THAT'S JUST A
SNAPSHOT. SURE MEDINA. THANK
YOU PROPOSED WILL GO DOWN TO
DOCTOR ALTHOUGH. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU YEAH
AND MEMBERS OF THE OPERA. YOU
CAN DAY. I THOUGHT YEAH THAT
COULD VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
ACADEMIC EDUCATION. NUMBER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSITY. I
WANT TO BEGIN BY SENDING TO YOU
A WAR WELCOME FROM OUR FOR. WE
WERE THE SACRAMENTO DOING IT
CAN LIKE THIS IS. I VERY
PLEASED TO BE WITH YOU TODAY TO
FILL IN THE US CSU CON. I THINK
WITH YOU THE I'M REALLY NEW FOR
MY CURRENT ROLE. I'M STARTING
MY. OKAY THANK YOU. I'M
RELATIVELY NEW TO MY ROLE I AM
BEGINNING MY FOURTH MONTH IN ON
THIS THIS NEW ROLE. BUT I BRING
THIRTY TWO YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. AND I SERVED AS THE
PROVOST AND VICE PRESIDENT FOR
ACADEMIC AFFAIRS AT CAL POLY
POMONA BEFORE ASSUMING THIS
ROLE AND SERVE THERE FOR SIX
YEARS AND HELP CAL POLY POMONA
NAVIGATE THE COVERT PANDEMIC.
I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
EACH OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU'VE OPPOSED. R. TODAY ABOUT
THE POST PANDEMIC UNIVERSITY.
LET'S START WITH THE MANDATES
AND PROCEDURES. FIRST I AM
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT ALL
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES. HAVE
RESUMED IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
AND ACTIVITIES AS OF THIS FALL.
AS EXPECTED THERE'S VERY
ABILITY ACROSS THE CAMPUSES DUE
TO DIFFERENCES IN THEIR
ACADEMIC PROGRAMMING PHYSICAL
SPACES AND REGIONAL PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE. THAT BEING
SAID. MOST OF THE COURSES
TAUGHT IN THE CSU ARE OFFERED
IN PERSON. AND MOST FACULTY AND
STAFF ARE BACK ON CAMPUS AT
VARIOUS INTERVALS. THANKS TO
THE STRONG COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND AGGRESSIVE
OUTREACH AS WELL AS ONSITE
VACCINE CLINICS AT EVERY CAMPUS.
AN EXTRAORDINARY COOPERATION
FROM OUR CAMPUS COMMUNITIES
MORE THAN 95% OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND 96% OF OUR EMPLOYEES. I
HAVE MET THE CAMPUS VACCINATION
POLICY. THOSE THAT RECEIVED AN
APPROVED MEDICAL OR RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTION. ARE SUBJECT TO
ADDITIONAL SAFETY MEASURES
INCLUDING ROUTINE TESTING AND
REQUIRED MASK WEARING. I'D LIKE
TO KNOW ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
LEARNING LOSS AND THE EQUITY
GAPS. AS WE RETURN TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. WE CONTINUE TO
ANTICIPATE THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS INCLUDING THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT OF LEARNING
LOSS ESPECIALLY AMONG OUR
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS. TO ADDRESS INEQUITY
AND ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS
COME TO US ACADEMICALLY
PREPARED AND CONFIDENT AS
LEARNERS AND SCHOLARS. WE
ENCOURAGE OUR CAMPUSES THIS
SUMMER TO USE FEDERAL FUNDS
PROVIDED TO HIGHER ED TO
INCREASE CAPACITY. AND PROVIDE
STUDENT FEE WAIVERS FOR THE CSU
EARLY START PROGRAM FOR MATH
AND ENGLISH EDUCATION. ONE OF
OUR TRANSITIONAL PROGRAMS
BETWEEN HIGH SCHOOL AND THE
FIRST YEAR THE FIRST SEMESTER
OF COLLEGE. CAMPUSES WERE ALSO
ENCOURAGED TO PROVIDE MORE
INTENSIVE SUPPORT FOR INCOMING
STUDENTS INCLUDING AND BETTING
TUTORING. PROVIDING ACADEMIC
COACHING CALLS SKILL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS AND ONLINE
LEARNING SKILL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. WE'VE ALSO CONTINUE
TO OFFER FLEXIBILITY IN
ADMISSIONS FOR THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE ACADEMIC YEAR.
INCLUDING A TEMPORARY
SUSPENSION OF THE USE OF THE A.
C. T. M. SAT. EXAMS ADJUSTED
MINIMUM GPA AND THE ACCEPTANCE
OF CREDIT NO CREDIT GRADING IN
A THROUGH G. HIGH SCHOOL
COURSES AND TRANSFERABLE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSES. THE
APPLICATION PERIOD FOR FALL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS CURRENTLY
OPEN. AND WORKING VERY HARD TO
SHARE THE NEWS WITH PERSPECTIVE
STUDENTS AS WELL AS K. THROUGH
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EDUCATORS. IN THE MIDST OF THE
PANDEMIC THE CSU SAW RECORD
ENROLLMENT IN FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY. HOWEVER THIS FALL THE
NUMBER SHOWS THAT WE'RE
GENERALLY BACK TO THE FALL
TWENTY NINETEEN LEVELS. WELL
OUR TRANSFER STUDENTS REMAINED
RELATIVELY STRONG OUR RETENTION
RATE WAS DOWN SLIGHTLY FROM THE
FALL TWENTY TWENTY COHORT. AND
WE HAD SEVERAL FEWER
APPLICATIONS AND THE SMALLEST
FIRST YEAR FRESHMAN CLASS SINCE
TWENTY TWELVE. WITH THE RETURN
OF HIGH TOUCH IN PERSON
OUTREACH OPPORTUNITIES SUCH AS
COLLEGE PLAYERS AND ADVISING
AND NOT WE CHECKED TIFFANY'S.
WE ANTICIPATE INCREASED
ENROLLMENT IN TWENTY TWENTY TO.
UNFORTUNATELY UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS WERE MOST REFLECTED IN
THESE DROPS. TO ADDRESS THIS
INEQUITY WE HAVE INSTITUTED AN
IMMEDIATE SYSTEM WIDE RE
ENROLLMENT CAMPAIGN. TO REACH
OUT TO OUR STUDENTS WHO HAVE
STOPPED OUT. I CONNECT THEM
BACK WITH THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED TO RETURN TO COLLEGE AND
GET BACK ON TRACK. I'D LIKE TO
SHARE NOW SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES AND LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THIS EXPERIENCE. THE
PANDEMIC CREATED MANY
CHALLENGES FOR ALL OF US. BUT
ONE SILVER LINING IS THE GROWTH
INNOVATION AND EXPANDED
INTEREST IN ONLINE METHODS OF
LEARNING AND STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES. I'M PROUD TO REPORT
THAT MORE THAN 60% OF OUR
INSTRUCTIONAL FACULTY HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CUMULATIVE HOURS OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPTIMIZE THEIR VIRTUAL COURSES
AND ENSURE ACTIVE STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT AND EQUITY IN THE
CLASSROOM. WE'VE ALSO HEARD
FROM MANY STUDENTS THAT THEY
PREFERRED HAVING THE OPTION OF
TAKING VIRTUAL COURSES BECAUSE
OF THE ACCESS AND THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THEY PROVIDE.
AS WE RESTORE RENEW AND RE
IMAGINE INSTRUCTIONAL
MODALITIES IN THE CSU. WE
ANTICIPATE CONTINUING TO OFFER
STUDENTS A RANGE OF MENTALITIES
TO SUIT THEIR PREFERENCES AND
NEEDS. JUST AS IMPORTANT TO
STUDENT SUCCESS IS THE FULL
MANY OF SUPPORT SERVICES THE
STUDENTS NEED TO ENSURE THEIR
SENSE OF BELONGING AND WELL
BEING. AS WELL AS THEIR
ENGAGEMENT AND ACADEMIC
PROGRESS. FROM CHATBOTS TO
TELEHEALTH ONLINE ADVISING AN
E. SPORTS. OUR CAMPUSES THAT
HAVE EMBRACED NEW TECHNOLOGY
TOOLS THAT PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS
WITH GREATER ACCESS TO SUPPORT
SERVICES. AND FINALLY THE
PIVOTAL VIRTUAL LEARNING AND
SUPPORT ILLUMINATED TECHNOLOGY
AS A BASIC STUDENT NEED.
THROUGH OUR NEW C. SUCCESS
INITIATIVE. EVERY INCOMING
FIRST YEAR OR TRANSFER STUDENT
AT PARTICIPATING CAMPUSES. I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
COMPLETELY FREE OF CHARGE A NEW
IPAD AIR. APPLE PENCIL AND
SMART KEYBOARD WHICH WILL BE
THERE'S TO USE FOR THE ENTIRETY
OF THEIR CSU UNDERGRADUATE
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE. MORE THAN
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED RELIABLE
HIGH QUALITY DIGITAL DEVICES
THIS FALL AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT THE RESULTS FROM PHASE ONE
WILL INSPIRE. ADDITIONAL
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE CSU TO JOIN
FUTURE PHASES OF C. SUCCESS.
I'D LIKE TO NOW ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF RECOVERY WITH ACCESS.
THE CSU IS AN ENGINE FOR SOCIAL
MOBILITY. AS OUR STUDENTS
RECEIVE A HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION. THAT PROPELS THEM
INTO HIGHER ECONOMIC STRATUM.
WE'RE PROUD THAT OUR STUDENTS
REFLECT THE RICH DIVERSITY OF
OUR STATE. WITH THE MOST
ETHNICALLY ECONOMICALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY DIVERSE UNIVERSITY
STUDENT BODY IN THE NATION. ONE
WAY WE ENABLE CALIFORNIA'S
RECOVERY WITH EQUITY IS BY
CONTINUING OUR COMMITMENT TO
OUR STUDENTS TO INCREASE THEIR
RETENTION AND GRADUATION RATES
AND TO ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS.
HERE I AM VERY PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT DEGREE COMPLETION
RATES ARE AT ALL TIME HIGHS FOR
STUDENTS IN THE CSU FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS. IN FACT WE'RE
GRADUATING APPROXIMATELY.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MORE
STUDENTS THIS PAST YEAR THAN
BEFORE OUR SIGNATURE STUDENT
SUCCESS EFFORT WAS LAUNCHED. IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS INCREASE IS
EQUIVALENT TO GRADUATING ON
ADDITIONAL CAMPUS THE SIZE OF
SAKE FRESNO STATE EACH YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY THE FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATES FOR FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS FIRST TIME STUDENTS
HAS RISEN. FROM 19% 233% AND
THE TWO YEAR GRADUATION RATE
FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS INCREASED
FROM THIRTY ONE PERCENT. 46%
HOWEVER EQUITY GAPS REMAIN VERY
STUBBORN. AND WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT WORK TO DO TO CLOSE
THOSE GAPS AND THIS IS BECOME
OUR- PRIORITY IN THE CSU. THIS
FALL WE UNVEILED AN EQUITY
ACTION PLAN AIMED AT
ACCELERATING OUR EFFORTS TO
CLOSE EQUITY GAPS. IN ADDITION
TO SYSTEM WIDE RE ENROLLMENT
CAMPAIGNS THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER. THE PLAN INCLUDES THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AND WIDE
USAGE OF DIGITAL DEGREE
PLANNERS ACROSS ALL TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES. TO GIVE
STUDENTS AN ACCURATE REAL TIME
ROAD MAP. OF THE COURSES THEY
NEED TO GRADUATE. EXPANDED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
MAKE UP ACADEMIC CREDITS BY
TAKING COURSES OVER THE SUMMER
OR DURING OUR WINTER
INTERSESSION. EFFORTS SHOULD
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE OUTCOMES
IN KEY COURSES WITH THE HIGHEST
ENROLLMENT OF UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING TANF FOR WITHDRAWALS
IN THESE COURSES WE NEED TO
ADDRESS WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THESE CLASSROOMS AND ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS HAVE. THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
THESE CLASSES. THE ELIMINATION
OF ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPEDE LOW
INCOME AND FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS FROM PROGRESSING
TOWARDS THEIR DEGREE. WE HAVE
ALSO ASKED CAMPUSES DEVELOP
THEIR OWN BOLD DATA DRIVEN
ACTION PLANS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
BACKGROUND INCOME OR ZIP CODE.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
THE LIFELONG BENEFIT OF A CSU
DEGREE. TO SUCCEED IN THE
WORKFORCE AND CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
STATE BRIGHT FUTURE. AS WE
EMERGE FROM THIS PANDEMIC OUR
GOAL IS TO EQUIP THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS THEY NEED
TO ADVANCE EQUITY AND JUSTICE
AND TO LEAD THE DIVERS AND
TALENTED WORKFORCE OF TOMORROW.
I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONVERSATION AND ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU DR ALTHOUGH OUR NEXT
PRESENTER DAVID O'BRIEN VICE
CHANCELLOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY- I WANT TO START OFF BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE IN YOUR
EXCELLENT TEAM OF CONSULTANTS
FOR ACCOMMODATING OUR LAST
MINUTE ADJUSTMENT AND APOLOGIZE
ON BEHALF OF ACTING CHANCELLOR
DR DAISY GONZALEZ WHO COULD NOT
BE HERE TODAY. AND OF COURSE
WISHING A VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY
TO CONSULTANCIES READING
ALRIGHT I ALSO THINK CHANCELLOR
ELOY ORTIZ OAKLEY OFFENSE
RETURNED FROM SABBATICAL LATER
THIS MONTH. AS WE LOOK AT THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO NOTE
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
BATTLE TWENTY. SIX BOTH COVER
NINETEEN AND THE STUBBORN
POVERTY CHALLENGES THAT
CONTINUETO AFFECT OUR OST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. AS THE
SYSTEM THAT SERVES OVER 70% OF
ALL PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENTS. THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
STEADFAST IN OUR COMMITMENT TO
THE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
DEPEND ON US FOR SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND WE REMAIN
UNAPOLOGETIC IN OUR COMMITMENT
TO DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION ON THE ROLE THESE
PLAY IN STUDENT SUCCESS. IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT. TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT ABOUT THE SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENTS ARE COLLEGES HAVE
MADE. HISTORIC SYSTEM REFORMS.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS OUR
COLLEGES HAVE INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS EARN COLLEGE
CREDENTIALS BY TWENTY PERCENT.
MEETING ONE OF THE SIX VISION
FOR SUCCESS GOALS AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE. THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE LEGISLATURE
ESPECIALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACQUI IRWIN OTHERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE. WE ABANDON THE
PLACEMENT SYSTEM THAT FAILED
STUDENTS SPIKE IN ACCURATELY
MEASURING THEIR POTENTIAL
REPLACING WTH ONE THAT IS
LEADING TO A MORE EQUITABLE
LEVEL ENGLISH
AND WE ARE FULLY COMMITTED TO
THIS WORK. NOW AS IT RELATES TO
THE CODE. AND MAKE WHICH THE
COMMITTEE ASKED ABOUT AS WE SIT
HERE TODAY I AM PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT. THREE QUARTERS OF
OUR SEVENTY TWO COMMUNITY
CALLED DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ENACTED A POLICY REQUIRING
STUDENTS OR FACULTY TO BE
VACCINATED AGAINST KOBE
NINETEEN AS A CONDITION OF
ATTENDING IN PERSON CLASSES OR
RETURNING TO WORK ON CAMPUS. I
WELL I DO WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT NEITHER THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE NOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
HAS THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO
ENACT A BACKSEAT NEED A SYSTEM
WIDE WE HAD STRONG. WORDS ARE
INDEPENDENTLY GOVERNED
DISTRICTS TO DO SO AND IT
PROVIDED TECHNICAL AND LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE THAT DO.
OVER THE LAST TWENTY MONTHS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE
REMAINED OPEN AND ACCESSIBLE
FOR CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT THE
ESSENTIAL INDUSTRIES ARE STATE
DEPENDS ON. AND I CANNOT THANK
OUR FACULTY AWARDS LEADERS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY OUR STUDENTS
ENOUGH FOR THEIR RESILIENCY.
THIS FALL AS WITH OUR- OUR
PARTNERS IN THE FOR YOUR
SYSTEMS. COLLEGES BEGIN PHASING
IN A HYBRID APPROACH WITH MANY
COURSES CONTINUE TO VIRTUAL
REALITY IN MANY MORE RETURNING
IN PERSON. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO PROVIDING YOU WITH A SUMMARY
OF PERSONALITY IN THE CHOICES
STUDENTS ARE MAKING IT A REPORT
THE LEGISLATURE NEXT MONTH. THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF OUR
CAMPUSES AND COMMUNITIES IS OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE OUR
COLLEGES TO LISTEN TO THE NEEDS
AND CONCERNS OF THEIR STUDENTS.
AS THEY ADJUST TO THIS RETURN.
MEMBERS CALL THE NOT CREATE NEW
CHALLENGES OR INEQUITIES
PERSIST IN OUR STUDENTS SO MUCH
AS IT SHINED A SPOTLIGHT ON AND
EXACERBATED IN MANY CASES THE
CHALLENGES THAT WERE ALREADY
THING. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT NATIONWIDE HAS
CONTINGENT HAS CONTINUED TO
DECLINE THE DECLINE IT THAT
BEGAN PRIOR TO VOTE WAS
WORSENED BY THIS ONCE IN A
CENTURY PANDEMIC. IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ARE THE BEST ESTIMATE WERE ABLE
TO GET WITH HER LATEST
AVAILABLE DATA. IS THE TOTAL
ENROLLMENT IN OUR SYSTEM
DECLINED BY APPROXIMATELY 15%
OR ABOUT THREE HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS FROM THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
UP IN HERE TWO TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
UNPACKING NUMBERS A BIT. WE SEE
THAT THE STEEPEST DECLINES WERE
AMONG AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS.
ERIC CAN STUDENTS MAIL STILL.
AND STUDENTS WHO ARE OUTSIDE
WHAT WE CONSIDER TRADITIONAL
COLLEGE GOING AGE IN PARTICULAR
AMONG ALL STUDENTS AGE FORTY
AND OLDER TOTAL ENROLLMENT
DECLINED BY OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS OR NEARLY A
THIRD OF THE OVERALL DECLINE.
SH AND I CALL OTHER SPECIFIC
CATEGORIES TO HIGHLIGHT OUR
CHALLENGES AND KNOW THAT THIS
IS WHO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SERVE. OUR STUDENT POPULATION
IS DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW
INCOME STUDENTS OF COLOR
WORKING STUDENTS STUDENTS
RAISING CHILDREN OF THEIR OWN
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
STUDENTS WHO ARE IMMIGRANTS OR
FROM AN IMMIGRANT FAMILY OR
BACKGROUND AND FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS THE PERSON HER FAMILY
TO GO TO COLLEGE. SO THESE
DECLINES ARE HIGHLY WORKING TO
US AND WE CAN'T THINK THE
LEGISLATURE NOT FOR RECOGNIZING
THIS TREND AND ALLOCATING NEW
FUNDS IN THE BUDGET FOR
OUTREACH ENGAGEMENT RECRUITMENT
ENROLLMENT AND RETENTION. PRESS
SECRETARY YEAH HOLD ON TO THE
STUDENTS HOWEVER I WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE WE CAN'T
FOCUS EXCLUSIVELY ON A ROLL NOT
AT THE EXPENSE OF OUTCOMES AND
STUDENT SUCCESS. AND THIS MEANS
ADDRESSING THE CRISIS OF
AFFORDABILITY IN OUR STUDENTS
BASIC NEEDS THAT IS FOR TOO
LONG HOW ABOUT THE ABILITY OF
STUDENTS TO SUCCEED IN OUR
SYSTEM. I WANT TO PERSONALLY
THANK CHAIR MEDINA AS WELL AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AND IN
THE SENATE SOCCER LEYVA AND THE
WHOLE LEGISLATURE FOR BEING
CHAMPION OF CALIBRATE REFORM
AND FOR SPEAKING OUT FOR
MILLIONS OF STUDENTS. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN OUR STUDENTS
IN MAKING MUCH NEEDED
INVESTMENTS IN BASIC NEED
CENTERS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
ON THIS COMMITTEE I ALSO JUST
WANT TO SPECIFICALLY RECOGNIZE
DR ARAMBULA FOR LEADING
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR TO CREATE
A CRITICAL LIAISON BETWEEN OUR
CAMPUSES AND COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES TO HELP
STUDENTS APPLY FOR SERVICES
LIKE CALFRESH AMONG OTHERS. AS
NECESSARY AS THE USE AND OTHER
NEW LEGISLATION AND INVESTMENTS
ARE. WE CANNOT STOP THERE. WE
MUST PRESS AHEAD AND CONTINUE
TO FIGHT FOR AN EQUITABLE.
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM THAT
ADDRESSES OUR STUDENTS TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE. OR AS WE
LIKE TO CALL IT THE TO COST OF
SIX. ON BASIC NEEDS WITH MY USE
THE ARM FINE AND GUIDANCE FROM
RELIGIOUS TO THE HOME FOR HOW
WE ADDRESS THESE ISSUES WE KNOW
THAT JUST AS IN THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION WE'RE HEARING MORE
AND MORE. DOCTORS NURSES AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND
OTHERS TALK ABOUT THIS CONCEPT
OF SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEIR
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS. WHAT ELSE
DOES THAT MEAN FOR US TO FOCUS
RELENTLESSLY ON STUDENTS
SUCCESS. IT MENS OUR COLLEGES
MUST CONTINUE TO INNOVATE AND
BREAK DOWN BARRIERS AND SILOS
AND WE MUST SUPPORT THEM FROM
THE SYSTEM UPS AND STATE LEVEL.
AMONG OTHER THINGS I'M PLEASED
TO KNOW THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THE FOUNDATION FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE BEATING A REPORT
STREAMLINED PROJECT. TO ALLOW
OUR COLLEGES TO MORE
EFFICIENTLY REPORT OUT DATA ON
PROGRAM OUTCOMES SO THEY CAN
SPEND LESS TIME ON PAPERWORK
AND COMPLIANCE AND RED TAPE.
AND MORE TIME DIRECTLY SERVING
STUDENTS. WE WERE ALSO PLEASED
AND VERY APPRECIATIVE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL ROUND OF FUNDING TO
CONTINUE IMPLEMENTING GUIDED
PATHWAYS IN OUR SYSTEM AS YOU
KNOW GUIDED PATHWAYS IS THE
FRAMEWORK BY WHICH WERE
ADVANCING OUR VISION FOR
SUCCESS. AND FINALLY. I WANT TO
KNOW THAT ONE MORE COMPONENT AS
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS TO
FOCUS RELENTLESSLY ON STUDENTS
SUCCESS. THAT IS CENTRAL TO OUR
EFFORTS IS OUR COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING EVERY STUDENT WITH AN
EQUITABLE CAMPUS AND CLASSROOM
ENVIRONMENT. TO DO SO WE MUST
ACTIVELY BREAKDOWN SYSTEMIC
RACISM IN ADVANCE ANTI RACIST
EDUCATION REMISSION IS SUCH AS
OUR NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR
STUDENTS TO TAKE COURSES IN
ETHNIC STUDIES. I THINK STUDIES
OBVIOUSLY IS AN AREA THAT
YOU'RE MEDINA IS VERY FAMILIAR
WITH IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OF COURSE I WANT TO THANK OUR
FACULTY FOR LEADING IN THIS
AREA. YEAH I THINK STUDIES
REQUIREMENT ENACTED BY THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS THIS- SUMMER
WAS INITIATED LED BY FACULTY
SUCH AS ACADEMIC SENATE
PRESIDENT DORIS DAVIS AND-
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
NEXT PANEL. WE MUST ALSO
CONTINUE EFFORTS TO DIVERSIFY
OUR FACULTY AND STAFF SIMILAR
TO OTHER THINGS THE PROPOSED
BROWN MADE. TO THE UC SYSTEM WE
HAVE OUR OWN PROJECT UNDER
FIRST EQUITY. AND INCLUSION IS
EVEN THOUGH WE CERTAINLY.
STUDENTS COLOR AND I. SEVENTY
OF FACULTY INTERESTED ARE WHITE.
AND FINALLY WE MUST WORK HAND
IN HAND WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ADVOCACY PARTNERS TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE AN EQUITABLE
SYSTEM OF ASSESSMENT. PLACEMENT
AND RONIT ON EVERY CAMPUS AND
THAT MEANS NOT JUST FULLY
IMPLEMENTING BUT STRENGTHENING
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH FIVE.
THE PIONEERING LEGISLATION WAS
ADVANCED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACQUI IRWIN AND THIS
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
MEMBERS THOSE ARE JUST A FEW OF
THE MAJOR AREAS IN WHICH OUR
SYSTEM CONTINUES TO WORSEN
OUTLOOK FOCUSED NOT JUST ON IN
WILMETTE PUT HONOR ROLE THAT
YOU STUDENT SUCCESS. WE KNOW
IT'S SIMPLY GETTING MORE
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS YOU KNOW
INCREASING THAT NUMBER ON THE
SPREADSHEET PROCESS TOTAL
HEADCOUNT IS NOT ENOUGH. WE
MUST DEVOTE ALL OF OUR ENERGIES
AND ATTENTION TO ELIMINATING
EQUITY GAPS ADDRESSING NOT JUST
CRISIS SYSTEM BASIC NEEDS BUT
THE CAUSES OF THAT CRISIS AND
TO PROVIDING A SAFE AND
EQUITABLE CAMPUS FOR ALL
STUDENTS. THAT WILL REQUIRE THE
SUPPORT OF NOT JUST OUR SYSTEM
COLLAGEN FACULTY LEADERS WHAT
ALL OF YOU IS THE ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES OF OUR TWO
MILLION STUDENTS AMONG OTHER
THINGS THAT WERE REQUIRE US TO
IDENTIFY CHAMPIONS. FROM AMONG
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
SYSTEM BUDGET REQUEST WHICH
SEEKS RESOURCES NOT JUST FOR A
SYSTEM WHICH IS THE LOWEST
FUNDED SYSTEM OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA ON A
PER STUDENT BASIS. BUT FOR
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED
UNDERSTAFFED CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WE'RE JUST ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EMPLOYEES
OVERSEE THE LARGEST SYSTEM OF
HIGHER. EDUCATION IN THE UNITED
STATES. I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR- FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS AND FOR
CALLING THIS TOGETHER TODAY TO
CONTINUE THIS ESSENTIAL
CONVERSATION. ON HOW WE RECOVER
EQUITABLY FROM COATED NINETEEN
BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU DAVID FOR A FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WILL GO NEXT TO
ALEX GRAVES VICE PRESIDENT FOR
GOVERNMENTAL. RELATIONS THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT.
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHEN MEMBER FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE A BRIEF UPDATE. ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE'S
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES MY NAME IS ALEX
GRAVES HERE TODAY ON BEHALF F
THE ICC U. R. SECTOR CURRENTLY
SERVES NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNDERGRADUATES. OF
WHICH 71% OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AS WELL AS ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
GRADUATE STUDENTS. IN MY TIME
TODAY I'D LIKELY I'D LIKE TO
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THE STATUS OF
STUDENT ROMAN AND PERSISTENCE
THIS FALL. THE STRATEGIES AND
TOOLS INSTITUTIONS ARE
UTILIZING TO MAINTAIN A SAFE.
AND HEALTHY CAMPUS COMMUNITY.
AND HOW INSTITUTIONS ARE
WORKING TO ADDRESS LEARNING
LOSS EQUITY GAPS AND THEIR ROLE
IN THE STATE'S RECOVERY WITH
EQUITY WORK. IN OCTOBER WE SAW
A SHORT SIR. TO OUR INSTA. AND
PREPARATION FOR THIS UP. FIFTY
RESPONDED AND THE DATA AND THAT
IN MY COMMENTS WILL BE BASED ON
THOSE FINDINGS. I'VE ALSO
PROVIDED COPIES OF A SHORTHAND
OUT WE PREPARED FOR THIS
DISCUSSION. LAST WEEK THE
NATIONAL STUDENT CLEARINGHOUSE
RELEASED NEW DATA ON ENROLLMENT
FINDING UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT NATIONALLY FELL
THREE POINT 2% IN OUR SECTOR WE
SEE SOME POSITIVE INDICATORS OR
AT THE VERY LEAST SIGNS OF
STABILIZATION IN OUR
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT. OR AS
THE MAJORITY OF INSTITUTIONS
REPORTED ENROLLMENT DECLINES IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE SEE MORE
INSTITUTIONS REPORTING THE
UNDERGRAD ROMIT HAS EITHER
INCREASED OR STABLE AND FALL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AT THE
GRADUATE LEVEL WELL WE FOUND
THE MAJORITYOF INSTITUTIONS
REPORT RELENTLESS STABLE ARE
AT. A GREATER PROPORTION OF
RESPONDENTS. INDICATED THAT
ENROLLMENT WAS DOWN THIS YEAR
COMPARED TO THE PRIOR YEAR-
CONSIDERING OUR SECTOR IS THE
LARGEST- EDUCATOR OF GRADUATE
STUDENTS IN THE STATE INCLUDING
THE LEADING PRODUCER OF NEW
TEACHERS AND CONTRIBUTING MANY
TO THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE.
THIS IS CERTAINLY A PATTERN WE
WANT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR INTERNAL
RESEARCH WORK. LOOKING AT
STUDENT PERSISTENCE RATES THE
MAJORITY INSTITUTIONS DID
REPORT RATES THAT WERE STEADY
OR HAVE INCREASED. HOWEVER
ABOUT 42% DID REPORT DECREASED
YEAR OVER YEAR PERSISTENCE
RATES. INDICATING THAT THERE'S
STILL MUCH WORK TO DO AN
EXAMINING INSTITUTIONAL
POLICIES AND SUPPORTS WILL ALSO
TRYING TO ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO
STOPPED OUT. TO RETURNING
CONTINUE THEIR STUDIES. ALL
INSTITUTIONS RESPONDING TO OUR
SURVEY- DID INDICATE THAT THEY
HAVE RESUMED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. WE ARE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE OUR INSTITUTIONS
WELCOME BACK STUDENTS THIS FALL
TO FULLY IMMERSE THEMSELVES AND
ALL THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT OUR
CAMPUSES OFFER. MANY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS AS YOU MAY KNOW
OUR RESIDENTIAL AND PROVIDE ON
CAMPUS HOUSING AND ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THOSE SAID AT THE
RESIDENCE HALLS ARE OPEN AT
FULL CAPACITY. WITH MANY
STUDENTS LIVING ON CAMPUS
UNIVERSITIES ARE EMPLOYING A
NUMBER OF STRATEGIES TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS AS WELL AS OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF. ARE
INTERACTING IN A SAFE AND
HEALTHY CAMPUS COMMUNITY. WE'RE
PLEASED TO SHARE THAT THE
MAJORITY REPORTED VACCINATION
RATES WELL ABOVE 90% BOTH FOR
THEIR STUDENTS AND FOR FACULTY
AND STAFF. AROUND 73% OF
INSTITUTIONS ARE REQUIRING
PROOF OF VACCINATION FOR
STUDENTS AND FACULTY OR STAFF.
WITH ACCOMMODATIONS FOR VALID
MEDICAL IN PERSON AND RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTIONS. THE MOST COMMON
PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGIES WE SEE
INCLUDE VACCINE PROMOTION MASK
REQUIREMENTS IN DURING
CONGREGATE SETTINGS. PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND INCREASED
VENTILATION CLEANING PROCEDURES
RANGING FROM MORE FREQUENT
CLEANING UP PUBLIC SPACES TO
THE AVAILABILITY OF HAND
SANITIZER ACROSS CAMPUS. WE'RE
ALSO LEVERAGING TECHNOLOGY AND
THINGS LIKE SYMPTOMS SELF
REPORTING OUT TO MUST BE
UPDATED REGULARLY WITH ABOUT
80% OF OUR INSTITUTIONS
UTILIZING SOME FORM OF THOSE
APPS AS WELL AS CONTACT
TRACING. ADDITIONALLY ABOUT HOW
FOR DOING SOME FORM OF
MANDATORY TESTING. HOWEVER WE
ALSO KNOW THAT HEALTH IS NOT
LIMITED TO PHYSICAL HEALTH.
THAT ALSO INCLUDES THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF THOSE ARE CAMPUS. AND
LAST YEAR AND A HALF WE LEARNED
THAT TELEHEALTH WORKS THAT
STUDENTS RESPONDED TO AN
UTILIZED IT. AND THEY
APPRECIATED THE ADDITIONAL
PRIVACY OF NOT NECESSARILY
HAVING TO VISIT A CAMPUS CENTER
FOR AN APPOINTMENT. IN TALKING
WITH SOME OF OUR STUDENT FARES
DIRECTORS WE HAVE HEARD THAT
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
REQUESTS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WITH STUDENTS BACK ON
CAMPUS. 72% OF INSTITUTIONS
RESPONDING TO OUR SURVEY
INDICATED THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED
AN INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR SUCH
SERVICES. GIVEN THE INCREASED
WELLNESS NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS
OUR INSTITUTIONS HAVE WORK TO
SHIFT STAFF TIME AND RESOURCES.
AS WELL AS CONTINUED
UTILIZATION OF TELEHEALTH AS-
AND THAT IS ONE OF MANY
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THIS IS
PART OF THEIR COMMITMENT TO
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS.
INSTITUTIONAL STAFF HAVE ALSO
REPORTED THAT THEY HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASED NEED FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AND ACADEMIC SUPPORT.
MANY HAVE UTILIZED FEDERAL
RELIEF FUNDS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL AID TO
STUDENTS AND ALSO WORKED
AGGRESSIVELY TO RAISE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR NEED BASED
AID. TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
WHO DID NOT FEEL THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PURSUIT- EXCEEDING
IT SEEMS TO NOT FEEL THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PURSUIT WAS NO
LONGER FINANCIALLY VIABLE. WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THE IMPACTS
OF KOBE NINETEEN ARE NOT
LIMITED TO THOSE STUDENTS WE
CURRENTLY SERVE. BUT ALSO THOSE
IN K. TWELVE WHOSE PATHS ARE
BRINGING THEM CLOSER TO OUR
INSTITUTIONS. WITH THE PASSAGE
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF AB ONE OH
FOUR EARLIER THIS YEAR. AT
LEAST THIRTY OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE INSTITUTIONS ARE
NOW ACCEPTING PASS NO PASS
GRADES. AND WE HAVE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ENSURE THEY'RE ALL LISTED ON
THEIR WEBSITE. AND ALSO THAT
OUR ADMISSION OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN IN COMMUNICATION WITH
THEIR LOCAL K. TWELVE PARTNERS
ABOUT THAT CHANGE. WELL SOME OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS WERE ALREADY
TEST OPTIONAL PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. MANY MORE HAVE WAIVED
SAT AND ACT REQUIREMENTS SINCE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN. BY OUR
COUNT- FIFTY SEVEN OF OUR
MEMBER INSTITUTIONS ARE NOW
TESTOSYN ALLIES OF THIS
ACADEMIC YEAR. WE DO NOT HAVE
SYSTEM WIDE DATA ON THE IMPACT
OF THIS SHIFT BUT WHAT WE HEAR
AND TALKING WITH SEVERAL OF OUR
MISSION OFFICES. IS THAT THEY
HAVE SEEN THEIR APPLICANT POOL
INCREASE ACROSS THE BOARD WITH
THIS CHANGE INCLUDING NOTABLE
INCREASES IN APPLICATIONS FROM
BLACK LATINO AND FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS. AS THE
STATE CONTINUES ITS WORK TO
RECOVER WITH EQUITY. WE
CONTINUE OUR WORK TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT LEAD TO
EMPLOYMENT AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. WE SUPPORT THE WORK
OF THE GOVERNOR'S RECOVERY WITH
EQUITY TASK FORCE WHICH
INCLUDED POMONA COLLEGE
PRESIDENT GABRIELLE STAR. WE
AGREED THAT THE PRESSING
CONCERNS AFFORDABILITY AND WE
ARE ALSO FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING
BASIC NEEDS THROUGH EFFORTS
SUCH AS THE INTERSEGMENT ALL
BASIC NEEDS WORKGROUP. WITH DR
LINDA MAKE MURDOCH FROM MOUNT
ST MARY'S UNIVERSITY
PARTICIPATING ON BEHALF OF OUR
SECTOR. WE ALSO KNOW THE
QUALITY DATA IS CRITICAL FOR
POLICYMAKERS AND PRACTITIONERS
AND AICC YOU HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN THE CRADLE TO
CAREER DATA SYSTEM WORKGROUP
OVER THE LAST YEAR. WE ALSO
SECURED A PLANNING GRANT FROM
THE TEAGLE FOUNDATION TO WORK
WITH OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PARTNERS AND IDENTIFY
STRATEGIES TO STRENGTHEN. AND
EXPAND TRANSFER OPPORTUNITIES
TO OUR INSTITUTIONS. THIS WORK
IS CURRENTLY FOCUSED ON TO HIGH
NEED REGIONS THE INLAND EMPIRE.
AND LOS ANGELES- WITH THE GOAL
OF APPLYING FOR A LARGER
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO EXPAND THIS WORK
STATEWIDE. THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE DID PROVIDE THE
FIRST INCREASE THE CAL GRANT A
WORD FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING OUR
SECTOR IN TWENTY YEARS. WE ARE
THANKFUL FOR THAT ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT THE WILL HELP FURTHER
SUPPORTS STUDENTS AND THEIR
PURSUIT OF AN EDUCATION. AICC
REMAINS FOCUSED ON ENSURING
THAT RECENT FINANCIAL
INVESTMENTS FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
AND STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN. BOTH OF WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY ONLY AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS ATTENDING A UC OR CSU.
IS EXPANDED TO PROVIDE SIMILAR
INVESTMENTS IN THE STUDENTS WHO
CHOOSE TO ATTEND ONE OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS AROUND THE STATE.
THESE ARE BUT A FEW OF THE MANY
WAYS IN WHICH WE ARE WORKING TO
SUPPORT THE STATE'S ROAD MAP TO
AN EQUITABLE RECOVERY. MUCH HAS
BEEN DONE AND THERE'S STILL
MUCH MORE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
OUR INSTITUTIONS REMAIN
COMMITTED TO THEIR WORK
REGIONALLY AND WITH THE STATE.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME TO SHARE
THESE UPDATES I'D BE HAPPY TO.
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
ALEX AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PRESENTERS FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS. IF THEY HAVE.
ANY ANY QUESTIONS. DR WEBER.
THANK YOU. THERE. THANK YOU
CHAIR I'M IN THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO PRESENTED- TODAY I
REALLY APPRECIATED HEARING
ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING
ON IN EACH OF YOUR INSTITUTION
I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
DONE TO NOT ONLY KEEP OUR
STUDENTS SAFE DURING THIS TIME
BUT ALSO THE COMMUNITIES SAFE
IT'S WHILE- BY ENCOURAGING
VACCINATIONS AND ENCOURAGING
MASK WEARING AN AND ALL OF THE
OTHER. PROTOCOLS THAT ARE IN
PLACE- TO HELP PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS. I'M
BEFORE I GUESS MY QUESTIONS I
WOULD LIKE TO STATE THAT I AM.
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES- WE
ARE HERE TODAY ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON.
IS- HOW TO RECOVER WITH EQUITY.
AND UNDERSTANDING THAT IN
KEEPING EQUITY IN MIND AND
KNOWLEDGE AND THE FACT THAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ARE OFTEN
TIMES THE DOOR TO HELP THOSE
WHO WOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. GET ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. YOU KNOW YOU
HE I WAS LISTENING TO THE UC
I'M REPORT AND- THEY HAVEN'T
NOTICED A SIGNIFICANT DECLINE
IN THEIR ENROLLMENT AND YOU
HAVEN'T NOTICED. A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE AT OUR CSU SYSTEM. BUT
THE FACT THAT YOU'VE HAD AT
LEAST A 15% DECLINE IN
ENROLLMENT AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WHERE IF ANYTHING WE
NEED TO HAVE AN INCREASE IN
ENROLLMENT. I'M IS VERY
CONCERNING. AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
IT I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
MORE ABOUT WHAT POLICIES
PROCEDURES AND WHAT WE CAN DO
FROM A LEGISLATURE A
LEGISLATIVE STANDPOINT AND-
BUDGETARY AB. STANDPOINT TO
HELP- IT'S ALWAYS DISCOURAGING
TO HEAR THAT. YOU KNOW THE AREA
THAT PROBABLY NEEDS MORE
SUPPORT IS GETTING THE LOWEST
FUNDING AND THIS THE LOWEST
STAFFED. WHEN WE REALLY IF WE
REALLY WANT TO GET SERIOUS
ABOUT EDUCATION EQUITY. AND FOR
ME WHEN SHE WOULD HAVE THAT YOU
ALSO CAN LEAD TO HEALTHIER
INDIVIDUALS AND HEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES IN THE FUTURE. THEN
WE REALLY NEED TO START GETTING
SERIOUS ABOUT. FINDING THOSE
AREAS EQUITABLY AS WELL. I HAVE
TWO QUESTIONS- SO YOU KNOW THE
FIRST QUESTION IS THIS PANDEMIC
IS HAS SHOWN ALL OF US IN
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT WE DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE TO DO THINGS THE
SAME AND I THINK THAT- EACH OF
YOU HAVE TOUCHED ON THAT YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT MODELS OF
TEACHING DIFFERENT MODELS OF
LEARNING. SO MY QUESTION FOR
YOU MY FIRST QUESTION IS
WHETHER OR NOT THERE HAS BEEN
ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT. CHANGING
THAT TUITION STRUCTURE. FOR
PEOPLE WHO WILL BE DOING.
EITHER HYBRID OR ALL. DISTANCE
LEARNING IN THE FUTURE. THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
CAN GO AHEAD AND TAKE THE
FIRST- RESPONSE THERE- YOU KNOW
I THINK CERTAINLY- IN THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF WITH THE
TRANSITION TO- ONLINE REMOTE
INSTRUCTION- YOU KNOW OUR OUR
INSTITUTIONS PIVOTED QUICKLY.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW EVERYONE
RESPONDED- ENACTED- ADMIRABLY
AND TRYING TO MAKE THAT
ADJUSTMENT QUICKLY ESPECIALLY
FOR RELEASED MANY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS WILL THAT ARE MORE
THE- SMALLER CLASSES LIBERAL
ARTS MODEL RIGHT THERE AREN'T
IS. RELEASED BY THE PANDEMIC
DID NOT USE ONLINE VIRTUAL-
CLASSES AND IS MUCH ABUNDANCES
PERHAPS OTHER INSTITUTIONS- I
AM NOT AWARE OF- MANY IF ANY
DISCUSSIONS RIGHT NOW AROUND
TUITION RESETS OR THINGS LIKE
THAT- CERTAINLY SEVERAL YEARS
AGO I THINK PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR%
WITH THE MILLS COLLEGE TUITION
RESET THAT THEY WENT THROUGH- I
DO KNOW THAT DURING THE
PANDEMIC THAT SEVERAL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS- IMPLEMENTED-
ADDITIONAL TUITION DISCOUNT
MEASURES. PARTICULARLY FOR
REGIONAL STUDENTS BECAUSE MANY
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
REGIONALLY SERVING- WHERE FOR
EXAMPLE- IT MIGHT EVEN SAN
DIEGO CHRISTIAN COLLEGE AND IN
YOUR AREA OF THE STATE THAT
OFFERED ESSENTIALLY- FINANCIAL
AID- MATCH IF A STUDENT'S CAL
GRANT ELIGIBLE IN THE REGION
AND THAT THEY WOULD BASICALLY
OFFER A COMPARABLE- ACCESS
POINT FOR. STUDENTS TO IF THEY
WERE TO ATTEND THE CSU- I THINK
CERTAINLY WITH THE CHANGE AND-
THERE ARE INSTITUTIONS OF SEEN
AND IN OUR SURVEY WE DID FIND
THAT A NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS
ARE THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
CONTINUE USING- ONLINE LEARNING
IN SOME FORM THAT MAYBE THEY
DIDN'T BEFORE- THEY'LL CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE THAT IN THE CONTEXT
OF THEIR OPERATIONAL- BUDGETS
AND NEEDS TO SERVE THEIR
MISSION. IT'S THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND I'D
LIKE TO ANSWER THROUGH THE CSU
LANCE AND SHARE WITH YOU THAT.
WE'VE BEEN VERY PUBLIC AND
COMMITTED TO KEEPING OUR
TUITION FEES FLAT. AND WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW AND ONE OF
THE MAJOR REASONS WHY I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT IS BECAUSE OF
THE SUPPORT THAT WE RECEIVED
FROM THE STATE TO ROUND OUT R.
OR **** SO WE DO NOT HAVE PLANS
TO INCREASE OUR TUITION FEES.
ALL THE WHILE WE KNOW THAT
COSTS ARE ALSO ACCELERATING
INCLUDING THE COST OF
TECHNOLOGY- PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND INVESTMENTS
THAT NEED TO BE MADE TO OFFER.
QUALITY ONLINE DIGITAL
EXPERIENCES FOR OUR STUDENTS. I
DO WANT TO REFLECT ON SOME WAYS
IN WHICH WE TRY TO EXPAND-
ECONOMIC RELIEF TO STUDENTS
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND IN
PARTICULAR. WHEN I WAS AT THE
POMONA CAMPUS WE- WEIGHT OF ALL
COURSE FEES WHERE STUDENTS PAID
ADDITIONAL COURSE FEES BECAUSE
THEY WERE IN A- IN A LAB FOR A
STUDIO WHERE THERE WERE
CONSUMABLE MATERIALS THAT
NEEDED TO BE INCORPORATED INTO
THE INSTRUCTIONAL DESIGN.
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T COMING TO
THE LAB THROUGH THE STUDIOS
THOSE FEES WERE WAIVED AND NOT
CHARGE THE STUDENTS. SEMELE
BECAUSE STUDENTS WERE NOT
COMING ON TO THE CAMPUS IS
THINGS LIKE THE RECREATION FEE
A STUDENT FEES TO USE THAT
ATHLETIC FACILITIES ALL OF
THOSE WERE REIMBURSED BACK TO
THE STUDENTS. SO WE TRY TO LOOK
TO SEE WHERE THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO- BUT THE
REIMBURSEMENT BACK TO THE
STUDENTS. THANK YOU I'M NOT
SURE FOR OUR REPRESENTATIVE
FROM- YOU SEE IS STILL ON STOP
GO TO MY SECOND QUESTION- YOU
ARE A GREAT YEAH YES DOCTOR ARE
WEBER IF I COULD JUST WAY AND
COULD I PUT AN UNDERSCORE ON
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE GOT SYLVIA
ARAMBULA HAD TO SAY OUR CHIEF
YOU TALKED ABOUT QUALITY ONLINE
DIGITAL EXPERIENCES AND I WANT
TO SAY THAT I'D PUT THE
EMPHASIS ON THE QUALITY ASPECT.
THAT THERE IS A HUNGER NOT JUST
FOR INCLUDES OF ACCESS TO ANY
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE THERE'S
A HUNGER FOR INCLUSIVE ACCESS
TO EXCELLENT EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES AND WHETHER WHETHER
IT'S IN PERSON OR- ALL OVER
OUR- DIGITAL. SO X. ALL.
REQUIRED INVESTMENT TIME
EXPERTISE MONEY AND RESOURCES
TECHNOLOGY AND ARE IN IN OUR
EXPERIENCE THE WHAT THE HIGHEST
QUALITY OF THOSE EXPERIENCES
ARE NOT NECESSARILY CHEAPER
THEY ACTUALLY MIGHT BE MORE
EXPENSIVE. SO HI WE HAVEN'T
THOUGHT ABOUT FOR MARIN
ANALYSIS AT THIS TIME- WITH THE
EMPHASIS ON PROVIDING
PARTICULARLY IF YOU WANT TO DO
IT INCLUDES NETFLIX ARE- IT IT
ACTUALLY MIGHT TAKE MORE
RESOURCES SO WE'RE WE'RE WE
RECOGNIZE THE PARAMETERS OF THE
STATE WE RECOGNIZE THE
PARAMETERS OF TUITION. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THE PARAMETERS OF OUR
HOME RESOURCE GARNERING
OPPORTUNITIES BUT OUR GOAL IS
TO MARSHAL ALL THOSE RESOURCES
TO PROVIDING EXCELLENCE IN- IN
THAT. IN EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
EVEN. IN THE DIGITAL SPACE.
THANK YOU SO MY SECOND ASKED
SPECIFICALLY FOR UC AND CSU
BECAUSE I HEARD THE OTHER TO
KIND OF TOUCH ON THIS ALREADY
IN THEIR PRESENTATION- WE KNOW
THAT TE PANDEMIC- HAS CAUSED
SIGNIFICANT- DISTRESS AMONGST.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE AND
EVERYONE HANDLES IT
DIFFERENTLY- YOU SEEN A SPIKE
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES OVER
THIS TIME PERIOD AS WELL AND SO
I'M JUST WONDERING IF I COULD
HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THE SERVICE IF THE IF THERE'S
BEEN AN INCREASE. IN THE AMOUNT
OF SERVICES IN THE PROVIDERS
THAT YOU ALL HAVE HAD- ON EACH
OF YOUR CAMPUSES. DOCTOR BROWN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO FIRST. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR ON ON
OUR- IN OUR CAMPUSES WE HAVE
FOUND AN INCREASED NEED- I AND
IT'S WHY IT'S- OUR FOR OUR- OUR
AND FRESHMAN ARE ENTRY STUDENTS
ARE TRANSFER STUDENTS. ARE
GRADUATE STUDENTS WE'VE ALSO
FOUND INCREASED MEDIA. OUR
STAFF AND OUR FACULTY AS WELL
THIS IS A STRESSFUL TIME WE ARE
IN THE MIDST OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WITH THIS IS I'M
PRESIDENT IN MY LIFETIME I'VE
I'M NOT EVERY EXPERIENCED
ANYTHING LIKE THIS AND- I'M A
PSYCHOLOGIST SO ALL RIGHT I
HAVE STUDIED THE HISTORY OF
THEIR DEVELOPMENT OF MARSHFIELD
AND IT PARALLELED OTHER TIMES
OF GREAT TRANSITION. IN SOCIETY
SO WE ARE IN THE- I'LL ARE VERY
CHALLENGING PERIOD OF TIME IT
IS NATURAL THAT PEOPLE AREN'T.
NEED SUPPORT- AND RESOURCES TO
COPE WITH THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT THEY FIND THEMSELVES%
SANDWICHED ARE NEW AND
UNPRECEDENTED MAY NEED TIME AND
COPING SKILLS TO ADDRESS THEM
WE HAVE ARE ARE EXPLORED
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT MECHANISMS
OF PROVIDING THOSE SUPPORT
INCLUDING TELEHEALTH OUT OF
FORMS OF- OF- OF SERVICES WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
TIME FOR BECAUSE OF SO MUCH OF
THESE- OUT OF THOSE STRESSES
AND EXPERIENCES WERE FILLED. IN
PHILLY THERE'S SOCIAL ISOLATION
ACCOUNT ACCOMPANYING THOSE
THINGS THAT THE ROLE OF GROUP
OUT AND KIND OF COUNSELING
SERVICES IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD BE BRINGING BACK. OUR
IN OUR OUR MOMENTUM OF
PROVIDING SUPPORT SERVICES AND
ARE AND- WE SHOULD BE ENGAGED
IN OUR CYCLE EDUCATIONAL AND
OUTREACH KIND OF SERVICES AS
WELL SO AND THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT I SEE HAPPENING. ON
OUR ON OUR CAMPUSES. THANK YOU
DR. LET ME LET ME ALL ELABORATE
ON THE IN. OF TELEHEALTH AND-
ITS USE AS THE DIGITAL OF
VEHICLE TO SUIT THAT STUDENTS
CAN USE TO ACCESS THESE KEY
SERVICES ALMOST ON- UBIQUITOUS
WAY GIVEN- THEY'RE DIGITALLY
MEDIATED. WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE INVESTMENT THAT THE
STATE MADE IN PROVIDING DIRECT
SUPPORT FOR STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND AS WE
VISITED JUST RECENTLY- TO
NEIGHBORING CSU CAMPUSES. THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDING CULTURALLY
COMPETENT AND DIVERSE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO THE
WORK FORCE WAS JUST VERY
EVIDENT IN EVERY CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAD BOTH WITH STUDENTS
AS WELL WITH AS WITH THE
LEADERSHIP TEAM. SO THIS
INVESTMENT WILL MAKE IMPORTANT
INROADS IN EXPANDING THAT T.
WORK FORCE BUT IN ADDITION TO
PERSONALITY THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
STUDENTS SHOW UP ALONG THE
CONTINUUM SOME WILL NEED CRISIS
IMMEDIATE- ASSISTANCE BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO FOCUS ON WELLNESS
AND PREVENTION STRATEGIES AND
I'M REALLY PLEASED TO SEE HOW
ON OUR CAMPUSES THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE IS EVIDENT IN THE
STRATEGIES AT THEIR UNFOLDING
ON THE CAMPUSES. AND SO IT IN
ADDITION TO THAT CONTINUUM I
THINK THE OTHER THING THAT I'M
SEEING. IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
COORDINATED CARE UNITS SO THAT
MENTAL HEALTH BASIC NEEDS
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES. ALL OR
WRAPPED AROUND IN THE HOME SO
THAT WHETHER IT'S A FACULTY
MEMBER WHO SENT AN ALERT OR
STUDENT WHO SHOWS UP IN ONE OF
THESE AREAS. THERE'S
COORDINATION AND RESPECT FOR
PRIVACY BUT ALSO-
RESPONSIVENESS THE ABILITY TO
THEN RESPOND TO THE COMPLEXITY
OF THE ISSUES THAT STUDENTS
HAVE TO THIS COORDINATED CARE
MODEL IS SOMETHING WOULD WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO DEVELOP AND
EXPAND AT ALL OF OUR TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES. THANK YOU.
RIGHT RIGHT. THANK YOU SIR GOOD
TO SEE EVERYBODY. AND ALL THE
PRESENTERS WHO ARE MADE THE
PRESENTATIONS- AS A VICE CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
I HAVE TO COME HERE- TO HEAR
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY AND THE
CERTAINLY AN OLDER LOVER SOLVE
ALL- EDUCATION FROM PRE K. TO.
COLLEGE GRADUATE SCHOOL. WE ARE
DEALING WITH THAT DISCIPLINE
THAT MAKE AND THEN I'LL
HOPEFULLY WE CAN CALL IT TOUGH
FOURTH DEPENDENT AND THEN THE
CAMERA HOW WE CAN. ARE SOME THE
PROBLEMS THAT THAT WE HAVE ONE
AND ENCOUNTERS. MMHM MANY-
TOPICS- THAT THAT YOU HAVE
MENTIONED. A COUPLE OF AREAS
SOMEONE OFF- THE CHARM- MANY OF
YOU- THE ESTIMATED AFTER
LEARNING GAPS AND EQUITY GAPS.
AND IF YOU CAN DEFINE LEARNING
GAPS ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT- FOR
THOSE WHO ARE. FOR PRESIDENT
DONALD IN PERSON IN CLASS AND
FOR THOSE SO WHO WERE LEARNING
ONLINE. I TALK ABOUT THE GAPS
BETWEEN THE TWO GROUPS. AND
THEN ALSO EQUITY GAPS A SEDAN
OR SIMILAR TERM- HOW DO YOU
MANAGER. I'M I'M SURE WE CAN
ALL ON- ANTICIPATED MUST BE
SOME DIFFERENCES SO
INEFFECTIVE- ARE LEARNING
BETWEEN NOW ONLINE IN PERSON-
ONLINE. AND- I WAS THE SOME TO
LEARN BETTER OR NINE SOME DON'T.
AND RIGHT NOW STATE LAW THE TO
ARE FORMS OF LEARNING.
CLASSROOM IS GOING ON DEPENDING
UPON THEIR TORIES OR DEPEND
UPON AUDIO VACCINATION- MANDATE
THE REQUIREMENT OF WAR REFUSAL
OF THAT UP. SO EVEN IN THE
MIDDLE OF- THIS- PANDEMIC- ARE
GOING ON HAVE YOU HAD ANY
TOURISTS- TO MANAGE WITHOUT
THOSE SISTER LEARNING GAP LAW
EQUITY GAPS. AND ONLINE THAT'S
A BIG GAS SO WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE- MAYBE AND- SO SHAKEN
BACKGROUNDS RACIAL BACKGROUND
DIFFERENCES INCOME VARIANCES
ZIP CODES ARE VERY SERIOUS OF.
JENDA VARIANCES SO THE ALL
KINDS OF THINGS WE CAN ANALYZE
BUT THE IN TERMS OF ALL WHAT
THE- IT IS THAT THE LEARNING
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW DID YOU
MEASURE THAT OR DID YOU DID YOU
MANAGER THAT'S THE POOL NOT
CHOPPED LANDING- HOW MANY
GRADUATES SO DURING THAT TIME
TO MAKE YOUR WITH THE LOCAL
LAST YEAR HAVE LANDED ON JOBS-
WAS THAT PART OF THE- EQUITY
MANAGEMENT TOOL. IN ALL IF YOU
CAN DEFINE HELLO HOW ARE YOU
GONNA- PROVIDE THAT TO A CLEAR
DEFINITION AND THE HOW YOU ARE
TAPPED YOU KNOW THE ONES TO
MANAGER AND THE WHAT YOU GONNA.
DO ABOUT THE FINDINGS. IF I MAY.
SALOMEA A YEAR I THINK IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION IN
TERMS OF BOTH. BEING ON THE
SAME PAGE AND IN HOW WE DEFINE
THESE CONCEPTS BUT ALSO HOW
WE'D GO ABOUT MEASURING THEM
AND ENSURING ALL IMPROVEMENTS
OR CHANGES ALONG THESE METRICS.
WHEN WE WERE FOR TO LEARNING
GAPS THROUGH S. WHEN I REFER TO
IT IN MY PRESENTATION. I WAS
NOT MAKING A COMPARISON OF
ONLINE VERSUS FACE TO FACE. THE
WAY I WAS USING LEARNING GAPS
WAS WHAT WHAT EXPERIENCE WHAT
KNOWLEDGE WHAT SKILLS DO OUR
STUDENTS. COME TO US WITH ON
DAY ONE. AND WE HAVE- IS YOU
KNOW SEVERAL YEARS AGO MADE A
COMMITMENT TO ELIMINATE
REMEDIAL EDUCATION. WE MEET THE
STUDENTS WHERE THEIR ACT AND
DETERMINE WHERE THEY'RE AT
USING A STANDARDIZED TESTS THAT
ARE ADMINISTERED IN HIGH SCHOOL
TO DETERMINE WHAT LEVEL OF
READINESS IN MATH AND ENGLISH
THERE IN. AND ONE OF THINGS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN WITH THESE
MORE RECENT INCOMING CALL
FORTH. IS THE SLIGHT INCREASE
IN STUDENTS WHO ARE BASED ON
STANDARDIZED TEST SCORES
PERFORMANCE IN THESE KEY
COURSES PERFORMING. AT A- AND A
FULL LOWER LEVEL ON THAT
CONTINUUM. WHAT THAT MEANS THEN
IS THAT WE NEED TO MEET THE
FINS WHETHER ACT IN INSURE THAT
IN THE SUMMER AS THEY
TRANSITION IN. AND IN THEIR
FIRST YEAR THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING THEM THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED TO CATCH UP AND BE
READY TO CONTINUE TO EXCEL IN
THEIR COLLEGE WORK. WHEN WE USE
IN THE CSU THE CONCEPT OF
EQUITY GAPS. IF INFORMED BY OUR
SYSTEM WIDE INITIATIVES THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. WHERE WE LOOK AT
THE RETENTION AND GRADUATION
RATES. OF STUDENTS IN
AGGREGATE. BUT WE ALSO BREAK
THEM DOWN AND SEE ARE THERE
DIFFERENCES. WITHIN THAT GROUP
BY PELL ELIGIBILITY FINANCIAL-
WRITTEN YOU KNOW FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. AS WELL AS RACIAL AND
ETHNIC GROUPS AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
BACKGROUND GRADUATE AT HIGH
LEVELS IN THE CSU AND THAT WE
CLOSE THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN-
IN HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS AND ALL OTHER SCHEMES.
YEAH DR CHOI IF IT'S POSSIBLE I
TO ADDRESS THIS FROM A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PERSPECTIVE- REALLY APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION AND JUST WANT TO
KNOW THAT AS WE THINK ABOUT
EQUITY GAPS. IT'S HARD FOR ME
NOT TO RESPOND TO THAT BY
SAYING SOMETHING ALONG THE
LINES OF EQUITY GAPS IS THE
NAME OF THE GAME. FOR OUR
SYSTEM BUT IT REALLY IS
SOMETHING THAT OUR SYSTEM.
STRUGGLES WITH PERSISTENTLY- WE
SEE GAPS ARE EQUITY GAPS FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN IT COMES TO- THE
REFERENCE TO DR ALBUMS MAJOR
MEDIA EDUCATION RESONATED WITH
US BECAUSE- WE CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT- AND WORK HARD TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SYSTEM IS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. CONSISTENT
MACKEREL PLACEMENT WE KNOW THAT
A DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH
NUMBER OF OUR BLACK CAN LET
NEXT STUDENTS AND THE STUDENTS
OF COLOR ON HER MOTHER FROM A
DESERT REGIONS- ARE PLACED INTO
REMEDIAL COURSES WORKSHOP MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT MAKE THEM LESS
LIKELY. TO SUCCEED IN DIRECTLY
TRANSFER LEVEL ARE WHAT WE CALL
COLLEGE LEVEL TRANSFER LEVEL
ENGLISH AND NOW. WE SEE EQUITY
GAPS IN TRANSFER ITSELF YOU
KNOW WE KNOW THAT TIME THE
LEGISLATURE IS MADE A BIG
PRIORITY OUT OF- STREAMLINING
THE TRANSFER PROCESS INCREASING
THERE IS WHICH I REALLY
APPRECIATE. FOR THE SALVATION
OF THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER IN TWENTY TEN FOR THE
ENACTMENT OF SOMETHING- NINE
TWENTY EIGHT OF THIS YEAR. BUT
DESPITE HAVING HAD THAT ETP
ASSOCIATED TRANSPLANT OVER A
DECADE WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT GAINS
TEARS ONE EXAMPLE FOR BLACK
STUDENTS WHICH IS A PROBLEM FOR
US AND FOR OUR SYSTEM- THE ONLY
OTHER THING I WOULD NOTICE IS
THE MAJOR SYSTEM WIDE EQUITY
GAP BUT WE STILL HAVE. ACCESS
TO FINANCIAL AID YOU KNOW
DESPITE SERVING A LARGER SHARE
OF STUDENTS THAT ARE LOW INCOME
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A MUCH LOWER
PERCENTAGE OF OUR STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE A STEAK CAL
GRANT WHICH IS OUR- PRIMARY
STATE FUNDED FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM. IN OUR FOR YOUR
PARTNERS DO SO EQUITY GAPS ARE
CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT OUR
SYSTEM THERE THEY ARE
PERSISTENT IN FINDING- AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK PART OF THOSE
EVERY. DAY SUCKERS AT THE
QUESTION. CHRISTCHURCH ALL
RIGHT I WOULD ADD. TO MIGHT.
HAVE ALREADY I THOUGHT WONDER
SAID. IS A YOUR QUITE. ARM ONE
OF THE- OF IT IS HOW DO YOU
KNOW. IN AND MAYBE EVEN ARE YOU
CAN ADD TO THAT WHEN DO YOU
KNOW. BECAUSE IF YOU IF YOU
NOTICE SOME OF. THE FEATURES WE
LOOK AT THEIR MULTIPLE
FEATURES. OF EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY. AND YOU CAN LOOK AT.
WHAT GRADES A PERSON IS OUT AS
STUDENTS ARE GETTING INTO CLASS
OR NOT YOU CAN LOOK AT WHETHER
THEY MOVE FROM OUT. FROM A
PRETTY MAJOR TO- ADD TO THE
MAJOR ARE YOU CAN LOOK AT
WHETHER THEY ARE RETAIN THE
FIRST YEAR WHEN THEY GRADUATE
WITHIN A PARTICULAR TO. PEER TO
TIME LAPSE THERE'S MULTIPLE
FEATURES TO THAT MATTER TO ALL
OF US IN TERMS OF THE
PERFORMANCE OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND WHEN WE SEE OUR- OUT
FEATURES ASSOCIATED THAT THAT
OUT THERE ALSO TRACK WITH
STUDENT SOCIAL DEMOGRAPHICS.
THAT'S A CONCERN TO US. IT'S A
CONCERN TO MY GOLLY IT'S A TO
US AND SEE SOME. AND WE'RE- IN
WIND FIND THEM TO FIND THE
SOURCES I'M NOT ONLY ARE THOSE
CAUSES MOBILITY. NOT ONLY ARE
THE GAPS THEMSELVES MULTIPLE IN
NATURE BUT THERE COULD BE
MULTIPLE TO COST TO AND SO
THAT'S WHAT IT ACTUALLY TAKES
SOME TIME SOME STUDIES OUR ON
GOING TO- TO LEARN WHAT THEIR
SECURITY THAT HAVE ROCKED OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. AND
TO- AT AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
FIXING THE PLANE EVEN AS WE- AS
WE'RE DRIVE FINE- SO THAT AS WE
GO ON WE'RE GOING TO DO WHAT WE
CAN TO IMPROVE- THE STATE OF
STUDENT EXPERIENCES I'M NOT I
THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR ALL MY
COLLEAGUES BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
I. HEARING AND- BUT WE'RE GOING
TO LEARN MORE AS TIME GOES ON
ABOUT WHAT SOME TO SPECIFIC
PROBLEMS ARE OUT WHO IT IS
DIFFERENTIALLY AFFECTING AND
HOW BEST TO TARGET AND TAILOR
AND VIC. INTERVENTIONS AS WE
MOVE FURTHER. THE GENTLEMAN YOU-
THAT ME THIS I AFTER GAP UP
DON'T KNOW THE U. K. ATTRIBUTE.
CALL THE NINETEEN. AS A FULL
COSTA FOR SUCH A AT THE DATE
GAP WOULD YOU AGREE TO THAT. I
WOULDN'T INTO EQUITY GAP BY
EXISTED EVEN BEFORE BEFORE LONG
BEFORE THIS BEEN DAMAGED. AND I
KNOWN AS A PART OF THE MEASURE
A TOOL TOOL- NARAL ELIMINATE
THAT KIND OF GAP. NO
LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL AND
DON ALSO USES SYSTEM ALREADY
ADOPTED THE POLICY. FOR A
COMMISSION STAND OUT THOUGH ONE
OF THE ACADEMIC OF POTENTIAL
GAUGE AS A T. WHILE IS TO T.
HAS BEEN ELIMINATED. NO THAT
CONCERNS ME A LOT. D. FOR THOSE
TOURS. ARE PROVIDED. SOME OF
THE MEASUREMENT FOR SUCCESS IN
COLLEGE A LOT OF. AND SO TO
SPEAK A POTENTIAL ACADEMICALLY
CAPABLE PREPARED. PEOPLE WERE
ACCEPTED THE ACCORDING TO THEIR
UNIVERSITY OR COLLEGE LEVEL
SOMEWHAT HIGHER SOME MORAL. AND
THE WHEN THEY ARE IN THE-
SIMILAR GROUP. THE ACT TO CAP
OR THE LOWER. BUT NOT ALWAYS-
THAT BACK AT THEM MEASUREMENT
TOOLS SOFT ELIMINATED. WHAT
KIND OF A TOWERS SO ON MISSION
TOUR SO I WILL NOT YOU'LL SELL
ONLY GPAS WHAT RECOMMENDATION
LETTER OF LETTERS. ALL PONDERED
THIS YEAR I MEAN TO ME. THAT IS
SO LIKE TO EMBRACING ANYBODY
FORCES COMPROMISE PUNE OFFLINE
I'M NOT GOING TO MEASURE YOUR
ACADEMIC POTENTIAL ABILITY. AND
THAT WILL CREATE THE EVEN FOR
THE ACCIDENT GAPS BECAUSE SOME
ARE PREPARED THIS AMOUNT
COMMENTATOR SOMEONE UP. WE
THINK ABOUT THAT DOCTOR DOCTOR
CHOI- I AM I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR INSIGHTFUL
QUESTIONS BUT IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME- WITHOUT RESPECT TO MY
VICE CHAIR- WILL BE BACK WE'LL
BE BACK IN JANUARY WILL BE
HAVING MORE OF MEETINGS OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
THE QUESTION THAT YOU POSE
RIGHT NOW. DR CHOI I THINK IT
IS A VERY- IT'S A GOOD QUESTION
VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
DESERVING OF THE ANSWERS FROM-
OUR SEGMENTS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION BUT IN THIS HEARING
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I'M
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD. IF
THAT'S ALRIGHT DR JOY. AND
PROMISE YOU THAT WE'LL HAVE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS
THAT. I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
ASK A QUESTION AND I WANT TO
WOULD BE FIRST BEFORE I ASK ONE
QUESTION. I WANT TO SAY THAT
MY- MY- DISTRICT OFFICE IS FIVE
MINUTES FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE. AND I
RECENTLY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE THEIR- FIRST TIME SINCE THE
PANDEMIC. WITH STUDENTS
PRESENT. AND WHAT A GREAT
FEELING THAT WAS WHAT A GREAT
FEELING IT WAS TO BE WITH OUR
CHANCELLOR THERE. HAD THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY AT CAL- WAS THERE
RECENTLY FOR A FOOTBALL GAME
AND THEN MOST RECENTLY AT
STANFORD- LAST SATURDAY. AND
THE PRESIDENT OF STANFORD SHARE
WHAT HE SAID IS THE JOY. OF
BEING ON CAMPUS THE JOY THAT IS
BEEN FELT BY FACULTY STUDENTS
AND STAFF SO I FELT THAT. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO MY FUTURE
VISITS ARE MEANT TO BE AT UC
SAN DIEGO. AND CAL STATE
FULLERTON IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
MY ONE QUESTION THAT I WANT TO
ASK EVERYONE- BUT RECENT
WASHINGTON POST ARTICLE
HIGHLIGHTED HOW DISABLED
STUDENTS. HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND
ON THE RETURNS TO CAMPUS
SPECIFICALLY THE LACK OF
RESOURCE RESOURCES FOR SUPPORT
IN THE CLASSROOM. AND ONLINE
SUPPORTS AND THE FEAR RETURNING
TO CAP TO THE CLASSROOM BECAUSE
OF THEIR IMMUNE COMPROMISED
SITUATION. SO MY QUESTION IF WE
COULD KIND OF QUICKLY WHAT IS
BEING DONE TO ENSURE. HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA RETURNED ON CAMPUS
LEARNING SO THAT ALL STUDENTS
ARE BEING PROVIDED EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITIES. TO ENGAGE IN
HIGHER EDUCATION AND WE COULD
MAYBE JUST GO QUICKLY THROUGH
ALL THREE SEGMENTS- WHEN I
START WITH. THE PROGRAMS BROWN
IF YOU DON'T MIND. APPROACH
GROUP YOU'RE ON MUTE. EXCUSE ME
I WAS SAYING I REALLY
APPRECIATE TO QUESTION CHAIR
MEDINA AND ARE. OUR THE
QUESTION ITSELF INDICATES THAT
NOT EVERYBODY EXPERIENCES THE
SAME ENVIRONMENT THE SAME WAY
AND ART AND HERE WE ARE
RETURNING TO OUR ON CAMPUS LIFE
AND SOME OF OUR STUDENTS WITH
CERTAIN KINDS OF DIFFERENT
ABILITIES ARE WERE EXPERIENCING
REMOTE ENVIRONMENT ACTUALLY AS-
AS AS MORE- CONDUCIVE TO THEIR
NOSE AT AND- AND NOW- RETURNING
TO CAMPUS. THEY DON'T WANT TO.
THE TO CA. WE GOING TO HAVE TO-
AT ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
ROBUST A DISABLED STUDENT
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND ARE ALL
OF THIS WORK OUT. VERY HARD TO
WANT TO RESOURCE THOSE PROGRAMS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO SERVE
STUDENT NEEDS AND THE LAST
THING I'LL SAY YES. IT'S VERY
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT- WE
ACTIVELY WORK WITH EVERYONE OF
OUR STUDENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN HAVE THE EXPERIENCE IS
AT THE BOTTOM POINT TO THEM SO
THIS IS AN ACTIVE AREA OF YOU
CAN ONLY INVESTMENT BUT OF
CONCERN. AND R. AS WE
TRANSITION BACK BUT IT OUT BUT
ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE THIS
ON THEIR RADAR SCREEN. DOCTOR
ARE REAL. HELLO BUT LONG. YOUR
PROBLEMS ARE I THINK WHAT.
DOCTOR BROWN HAS UNDER IS
REALLY THE KEY POINT IN THAT IS
THAT THIS IS AN ACCESS AND
EQUITY ISSUE. AND THAT STUDENTS
WHO COME TO US WITH A VARIETY
OF DISABILITIES OR WORK OR
CONSTRAINTS ON THEIR THEIR
ABILITY TO ACCESS LEARNING IN
THE QUOTE TRADITIONAL WAY. WE
NEED TO MEET THEM WHERE THEY'RE
AT AND ONE OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
FINDING FOR EXAMPLE IS THAT
WHEN WE STARTED TO PLAN FOR THE
RE POPULATION OF OUR STUDENTS.
WE HAVE TO INVEST IN DIFFERENT
TYPES OF MASS FOR OF
INSTRUCTORS WHO NEED HELP
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS IN
THEIR CLASSROOM NEEDED TO READ
THEIR LIPS. OR ON TRANSLATORS
SO IT'S A REALLY THINKING ABOUT
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THOSE
STUDENTS. BUT ALSO. RECOGNIZING
AS WAS POINTED OUT THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME STUDENTS WHO. WHO
MAY HAVE. MOBILITY CHALLENGES
WHO MAY FIND IT MORE CONVENIENT
TO ACCESS HIGHER ED THROUGH.
DIGITAL MEDIATED FORMATS SO I
THINK THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
HIGHER IT HAS. IS TO PROVIDE.
MORE FLEXIBLE. AND ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY FORMS OF
INSTRUCTION. AND THOSE
MODALITIES I THINK POST
PANDEMIC ARE GOING TO BE MUCH
MORE VERY. AND WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT. WITH THAT COMES A
COMMITMENT TO THE HIGHEST
QUALITY AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
ACCESS TO THIS VARIOUS
MODALITIES. THANK YOU AND THEN
GOING TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
DAVID YOU'RE THERE. YES CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE OTHER IS
A GREAT QUESTION IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WON'T REPEAT
TOO MUCH OF WHAT PROGRAMS
BROWN- DR ALVA SAID BECAUSE I
THINK WE- ACTIVE COULD NOT
AGREE MORE WITH WHAT THEY EACH
SIDE YOU KNOW IT'S IT REALLY IS
DEPENDENT ON INDIVIDUAL STUDENT
NEEDS AND CIRCUMSTANCES THERE
IS NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTION- AND THE ONLY THING
THAT I WOULD ADD TO THAT IS
THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO ADAPT TO
THIS NEW REALITY. IT NEEDS TO
BE STUDENT VOICES DRIVING THESE
DECISIONS RIGHT IN IN THE ROOM
AND CENTER- FORMER PRESIDENT
THE STUDENT CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
LIKE TO SAY A NOTHING ABOUT US
WITHOUT US WE COULDN'T AGREE
MORE AND I KNOW THE OTHER
SYSTEMS WORD OUT AS WELL AND I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ENGAGE WITH OUR
FACULTY BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE IN THE CLASSROOM
WHETHER VIRTUAL OR IN PERSON
WITH THE STUDENTS AND ENSURE.
THAT THEIR- THAT THEIR NEEDS
AND THEIR VOICES AND FEEDBACK
IS- IS BEING YOU KNOW-
PRIORITIZE THE PURPOSE
CONVERSATION BUT IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND WE DO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
THE FUTURE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
LOOKS LIKE IS ONE THAT IS
COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY
INCLUSIVE AND RECOGNIZES THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF STUDENTS WITH
ANY KIND OF DISABILITY HALF.
THANK YOU AND ALEX REALLY
INDEPENDENCE I MEAN I WOULD
ECHO MUCH OF WHAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SAID I THINK THE ONLY
THING I WOULD ADD IS THAT- FOR
DISABLED STUDENTS AT FACULTY
STAFF AS WELL AS- ARE IMMUNE
COMPROMISED STUDENTS FACULTY
AND STAFF- I THINK IS OTHERS
MENTIONED OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
TRYING PROVIDE AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE- VOTE
FOR STUDENTS TO ATTEND CLASSES
REMOTELY IF THEY DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE BEING ON CAMPUS FOR
WHATEVER REASON- OR IT'S EASIER
FOR THEM TO ACCESS THEIR
COURSES OR OTHER SERVICES FROM
HOME. SAME THING FOR OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF A NUMBER OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS OF IMPLEMENTED
FLEXIBLE WORK ARRANGEMENTS AS
WELL FOR THOSE WHO MAKE IMMUNO
COMPROMISED OR OTHERWISE- AND I
THINK IT ALSO WILL DEPEND YOU
KNOW- WE HAVE MANY INSTITUTIONS
AND. AND LOS ANGELES AREA SAN
DIEGO AND OTHER THE STATE THAT.
HAVE WHETHER THAT'S MORE
CONDUCIVE TO OUTDOOR. WHICH MAY
OF OUR ANSWER. OF A- AS A
STRATEGY. AND SO I THINK YOU
KNOW THAT IS AN ADDITIONAL
LAYER OF- NOT ONLY MODALITY
THAT PLACE- I THINK IS ANOTHER
THING THAT STUDENTS WILL
CONSIDER INSTITUTIONS ARE
TRYING TO. WORK THROUGH TO
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY SO THAT
EVERYONE FEELS AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE ON OUR CAMPUS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSES I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING WITH US TODAY. IT
IS UP TO DATE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WITH THAT WILL
TRANSITION TO OUR SECOND- A
PANEL ON THE GROUND RESPONSES
IN THE COVE IT NINETEEN ERA.
AND WE HAVE WITH THIS DELORES
DAVISON PRESIDENT OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ROBERT
ORDERS WHICH CHAIR OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
WIDE ACADEMIC SENATE. IT IDLE
CHAVEZ PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHRISTIAN MALHOTRA VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND
STEVE DORSEY THE THIRD
PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION FOR LAST YEAR
UNIVERSITY. AND WE'LL WE'LL
CLEAN UP HERE BEFORE YOU COME
UP- I KNOW. ROBERT COURSE WHICH
WILL BE PRESENTED VIA WEBEX.
AND. MAYBE WE COULD BE A.
ROBERT IF YOU'RE THERE. YOU
COULD PRESENT FIRST IF YOU'RE
THERE. I AM SURE IT DID NOT GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. THE DAMAGE UP
INTO THE ACTIVITIES OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO BE
SURE YEP FACULTY DIVISION ON A
DIME FROM IN PERSON TO REMOTE
INSTRUCTION. RESEARCH SUFFERED
FOR MANY BECAUSE OF THAT TIP IT
AND BECAUSE MANY FACULTY COULD
NOT ACCESS LABS WERE PERFORMING
SPACES OR FIELD SITES OR
ARCHIVES. KEEPING THE
UNIVERSITY FUNCTIONING UNDER
THE CONDITIONS OF THE PANDEMIC
REQUIRED VAST AMOUNTS OF EXTRA
WORK ON THE PART OF MANY
FACULTY AND MOST ADMINISTRATORS.
LAST SPRING YOU SEE SENATE
LEADERSHIP CONDUCTED A SURVEY
OF THE FACULTY EXPERIENCED
UNDER COLD. IN THIS SURVEY WE
HEARD FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE OF
UC FACULTY ACROSS OUR TEN
CAMPUS LET ME IN VERY SOME OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS THE SURVEY.
ABOUT FORTY FIVE HUNDRED FOR.
THE INSTRUCTORS WHO
PARTICIPATED 81% REPORTED
HAVING NO PRIOR EXPERIENCE WITH.
INSTRUCTION SO THE SHIFT TO
REMOTE REQUIRED A MAJOR MAJOR
EFFORT IN MOST RESPECTS THAT
EFFORT PAID OFF THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC STUDENT ENROLLMENT
STEADY AND STUDENTS WERE ABLE
TO TAKE THEIR COURSES FANS AND
THEIR PROGRAMS OF STUDY. OF
COURSE THE OVERHEAD COSTS LET
ME FIRST SPEAK TO THE FACT THE
SIDE OF EXPERIENCE. 75% OF
FACULTY RECORDED A HIGHER
WORKLOAD BECAUSE OF THE SHIFT
TO REMOTE INSTRUCTION AND THE
DIFFICULTIES OF PREPARING%
COURSES IN THAT MODALITY.
BAKALY RECEIVED HELP FROM
CAMPUS TEACHING AND LEARNING
UNITS BUT PERHAPS EVEN MORE
FROM THEIR FACULTY COLLEAGUES.
41% SAID THAT PARTICULAR
OBLIGATIONS AFFECTED THEIR
TEACHING AND THAT WAS PRIMARILY
PRAYER TICKING RESPONSIBILITIES
WHICH FALLS SOMEWHAT MORE ON
WOMEN AND MEN. 36% OF FACULTY
REPORTED THAT THE RESEARCH
SUFFERED GREATLY ANOTHER 42%
RESTORED BOB THERE RESEARCH
SUFFERED SOMEWHAT. THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT RESEARCH WITH SOMEWHAT
GREATER FOR WOMEN ON ACTIVE
DUTY AND FOR FACULTY IN THE
JUNIOR RANKS WHICH FAR MORE
DIVERSE. 80% OF FACULTY
REPORTED BEING MORE FLEXIBLE
AND ACCOMMODATING TOWARD
STUDENTS INCLUDING ATTENDING TO
STUDENT MENTAL DISTRESS. A
SURVEY ON INCLUDED A FEW OPEN
SECTIONS WHERE PEOPLE CAN WRITE
COMMENTS HERE FACULTY UNLOADED.
HERE'S A PARTICULARLY POIGNANT
BUT NOT UNUSUAL CONFESSION
QUOTE. I'VE HAD LITTLE TIME
LITTLE TO NO TIME TO RESEARCH
SINCE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY I AM
MANAGING A CHILD'S REMOTE
EDUCATION HOUSEHOLD MAINTENANCE
MY FAMILY'S EMOTIONAL STATUS MY
STUDENTS EMOTIONAL STATUS MY
COLLEAGUES IN MOTION STATUS. MY
DEPARTMENT IS IN POLITICAL
SOCIAL CRISIS I AM BUILDING A
NEW REMOTE COURSES ON THE FLY
MY SERVICE OBLIGATIONS HAVE
HUGELY INCREASED AND I AM
EXHAUSTED EXHAUSTED IN CAPS I
WANT TO QUIT END QUOTE. THE
UNIVERSITY CONVENE THE SENATE
ADMINISTRATION WORK GROUP ON
MILLION GETTING THE IMPACTS OF
COVERT ON FACULTY CAREERS.
ELIMINATOR A REPORT TO THE
CAMPUSES THIS FALL I CO CHAIR
OF THAT COMMITTEE WE
RECOMMENDED A RETHINKING OF THE
CRITERIA FOR FACULTY MEREDITH
PROMOTION. WE PROPOSED TO RE
HELP RESTART RESEARCH WITH
FUNDS AND PROPOSALS TO ADDRESS
FACULTY STRESS. NOW TO THE
STUDENTS CITED THE EXPERIENCE
YOU KNOW THAT THESE ARE FACULTY
IMPRESSIONS OF THE STUDENT
EXPERIENCE. IN THIS SURVEY 58%
OF FACULTY RATED GRADUATE
STUDENT ATTENDANCE COURSES
OFFERED SYNCHRONOUSLY S.
EXCELLENT AND VERY GOOD IN
CONTRAST 35% RATED
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
ATTENDANCE AS EXCELLENT AND
VERY GOOD. FRANKLY REPORTED
THAT IT WAS DIFFICULT TO KNOW
IF STUDENTS IN MEDIUM SIZED AND
LARGER UNDERGRADUATE CLASSES
WERE PRESENT BECAUSE MANY
STUDENTS KEPT THEIR CAMERAS OFF
THROUGH THE ENTIRE CLASS
SESSIONS. MANY FACULTY WROTE
THAT UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
SEEMED LESS ENGAGED WITH CLASS
MATERIALS AND THEY ARE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT OR PRECISELY THE
LACK THEREOF WAS PERHAPS THE
SINGLE MOST MENTIONED
OBSERVATION AND THE SURVEY
QUESTIONS ABOUT INSTRUCTION.
IT'S ONE INSTRUCTOR WROTE QUOTE.
STUDENT INVOLVEMENT IN CLASS
HAS OVERALL DRAMATICALLY
DECREASED IN JUST ONE YEAR IT
BECAME A HABIT TO NEVER JOIN A
CLASS WITH A CAMERA ON AND TO
REALLY ALMOST NEVER ASK
QUESTIONS IN CLASS AND QUOTE.
ANOTHER UNFORTUNATE OUTCOME OF
THE SITUATION IS THAT. THOSE
THINGS VERY WELL. MANY FACULTY
COMMENTED THAT THEY FOUND IT
DIFFICULT TO WRITE THE TYPE OF.
DETAILED HIGH QUALITY LETTERS
OF RECOMMENDATION IT HELPS
STUDENTS OBTAINING COMPETITIVE
POSITIONS INTERNSHIPS AND OFFER
FOR GRADUATE AND PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL. THE SURVEY RESULTS
SUGGEST THAT REMOTE INSTRUCTION
AT LEAST UNDER PANDEMIC
CONDITIONS WHAT'S LESS
EFFECTIVE THAN IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. 42% OF FACULTY
INDICATED THEY BELIEVED THAT
STUDENTS HAVE LESS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE COURSE
MATERIAL. 31% BELIEVE STUDENTS
HAD MORE ACADEMIC DIFFICULTY IN
REMOTE INSTRUCTION COMPARED TO
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. THE
SURVEY ALSO TRIED TO GET IN
ANOTHER DEFEAT THE MENTION OF
THE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
ACADEMIC DISHONESTY AMONG
STUDENTS WE ASK THIS BECAUSE
THERE IS INCREASING CONCERN
AMONG COLLEGE INSTRUCTORS
ACROSS THE NATION ABOUT
ACADEMIC INTEGRITY. GRADUATES
SEEMINGLY IN EVER LARGER
NUMBERS ARE USING EXTERNAL
STUDENT TUTORING WEBSITES TO
GET ANSWERS TO HOMEWORK
ASSIGNMENTS AND TEST QUESTIONS.
THIS CONCERN INTENSIFIED DURING
THE PANDEMIC BECAUSE ALL
HOMEWORK ASSIGNMENTS AND TESTS
AND PAPERS AND STUFF WE'RE DONE
REMOTELY. 54% OF FACULTY.
REPORTED THAT THEY PERCEIVED
ACADEMIC DISHONESTY TO BE
HIGHER OR MUCH HIGHER DURING
THAT STRETCH. BOB LET ME NOT
CONVEY AN IMPRESSION OF BLAMING
STUDENTS THE PANDEMIC AND
LOCKED THEM OR HARD ON EVERYONE
AND MOST POIGNANT ASPECT OF
FACTLY RESPONSES WAS THEIR
SENSE OF STUDENTS EXPRESSED
ABOUT HARDSHIP. STUDENTS
EXPRESS THEIR PROFESSORS WIDE
RANGE OF PROBLEMS FOR COURSE
RELATED DIFFICULTIES TO
OVERWHELMING PERSONAL
CHALLENGES INCLUDING HIGH RATES
OF PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
DISTRESS. IN MANY OF THE OPEN
ENDED COMMENTS ON THE SURVEY IT
WAS CLEAR HOW DIFFICULT THE
SITUATION WAS FOR EVERYONE. AS
ONE PROFESSOR WROTE QUOTE.
EVERYTHING WAS TERRIBLE FOR MY
STUDENTS. IT WAS AWFUL OPENING
MY EMAILS AND QUOTE.
NOTWITHSTANDING IT IS IMPORTANT
TO CELEBRATE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY DID ITS JOB
FACTORYTALK COURSES STUDENT.
CHRIS WORK PASSED AND MOVED TO
HAD DEGREES WERE CONFERRED.
THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION OUT THERE
THAT NOT MUCH WAS LEARNED AT
UNIVERSITY DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUT I WOULD SAY IT'S TOO EARLY
TO COME TO THIS CONCLUSION. OR
WHETHER LEARNING LOSS IT'S
BEING CALLED WAS DIFFERENT
ACROSS DIFFERENT GROUPS OF
STUDENTS AND WHAT THE LONG
RANGE EFFECTS. WILL BE THAT
SAD. THE CONCEPT OF LEARNING
WERE ALL LOST HAS ALREADY
ENTERED THE LEXICON AND WILL BE
TALKED ABOUT EVEN WITHOUT REAL
DATA I THINK WE NEED THE DATA.
TO THAT END WE SHOULD LOOK
CLOSELY AT HOW THE NEXT YEAR
UNFOLDS AND WHAT MIGHT BE KEY
INDICES TO TRACK WE MIGHT
EXAMINE FOR EXAMPLE WHETHER
CONCEPTS COVERED IN A
PRELIMINARY COURSE ARE
INTEGRATED AND USED BY STUDENTS
AS THEY MOVE INTO THE NEXT
COURSE IN THE SEQUENCE. MY OWN
SENSE OF THE WAY TO RECOVER
WITH EQUITY IS TO GET STUDENTS
AND FACULTY AND STAFF BACK TO
CAMPUS. BACK TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION BACKED INTO OUR
LIVING BACK TO THE INTERNET
PRESS. FOUND SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS THAT FUEL LEARNING
AND PERSONAL GROWTH. WITHOUT
HICCUPS OF CAMPUS RE OPENING
THIS FALL THAT ENERGY AND JOY
AS CHAIR MEDINA HAS TALKED
ABOUT THE ENERGY ENJOY OF
EVERYONE ON THE CAMPUS IS
PALPABLE AND LEARNING. FOUND
DEEP LEARNING IS HAPPENING. AND
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU AND NOW IF
WE COULD GO BACK TO DELORES
PRESIDENT OF ACADEMIC SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THANK YOU TERMINATE I
COULD AFTERNOON SHERMAN YOU
KNOW MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATIVE STAFF. MY NAME
IS DORIS DAY OF SOME OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ACADEMIC
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY AND FOR PROVIDING A LIST
OF QUESTIONS THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO ANSWER- I'M GONNA START WITH
TALKING ABOUT THE MITIGATION OF
LEARNING LOSS AND THE EQUITY
GAPS HAT NEED TO BE CLOSE
THAT- AS VICE CHANCELLOR
O'BRIEN POINTED OUT WERE NOT
CREATED ENTIRELY BY THE
PANDEMIC PANDEMIC BUT WE'RE IN
FAST. FACT EXACERBATED BY IT
SECONDLY I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE TRANSITION TO ONLINE
LEARNING- AND WHAT WAS PROVIDED
TO FACULTY AND STUDENTS AND I
WILL DEFER THE SECTION ABOUT
STUDENTS TO- MY COLLEAGUE-
DRIVER THERE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES STUDENT SENATE- I
REALLY WANT YOU TO HEAR FROM
HIM SO I'M GOING TO SPEAK AS
QUICKLY AND AS- LIMITED LISTS
ARE LIMITED AS POSSIBLE SO THAT
YOU CAN HAIR FROM- A STUDENT ON
HE GROUND TO EXPERIENCED ALL
OF THIS IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS. I WILL TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT MY PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE PANDEMIC WITH ME THE
BARRIERS AND CHALLENGES ABOUT
RETURNING TO CAMPUS- TALKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE ACADEMIC
AND PROFESSIONAL MATTERS.
RATHER THAN WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS AND THEN FINALLY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT RECOVERY WITH
EQUITY IN WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
FOR OUR STUDENTS. SO FIRST OF
ALL WE OBVIOUSLY EXPERIENCED- A
SIGNIFICANT DROP IN THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS THAT WERE ABLE TO
TAKE CLASSES FULL TIME- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WAS ABLE TO
DO IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY WHICH IS HIGHLY UNUSUAL
FOR AN ACADEMIC SENATE VICE
PRESIDENT. IS TO ACTUALLY TEACH
A CLASS- NORMALLY WE ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO TEACH OUR SCHEDULES
ARE TOO CRAZY BUT- I HAD BEEN
PERMITTED TO TEACH ONE ONLINE
CLASS IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THING I SHOULD POINT
OUT IS THAT I'VE TAUGHT ONLINE
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX THIS
WAS NOT A DIFFICULT TRANSITION
FOR ME- I HAD BEEN DOING THIS
FOR ALMOST THREE DECADES TO AND-
HALF DECADE. AT THAT POINT. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS I NOTICED
IMMEDIATELY WAS THAT THE
MAJORITY OF MY STUDENTS WERE
NOT PREPARED FOR THE
TRANSITION. MANY OF THEM
STRUGGLED WITH A WIDE VARIETY
OF ISSUES INCLUDING THEIR OWN.
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS. THEIR
INABILITY TO ACCESS MATERIALS.
THEIR LACK OF TECHNOLOGY- AND
QUITE FRANKLY IT MADE ME MORE
COMPASSIONATE. IT'S MADE ME A
BETTER TEACHER. WITH WHAT I
WENT THROUGH- DURING THAT
SPRING TWENTY TWENTY. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WOULD SAY
CLEARLY ABOUT THE EQUITY GAPS
AND THE NEED TO MITIGATE THE
LEARNING LOSS IS THAT WE NEED
MORE DATA- WE NEED TO SHARE
STUDENT SURVEY DATA. THE
STUDENT SENATE DID A TOWN HALL
IN A SERIES OF SURVEYS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE.
WE NEED THAT TO BE EXPANDED- AS
YOU'RE WELL AWARE WE COVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN COLLEGES.
IN ALL BUT ONE COUNTY OF THE
STATE. WE DO NOT HEAR FROM SOME
OF THE STUDENTS THAT WE NEED TO
HEAR FROM BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
PARTICIPATE OR THEY'RE UNABLE
TO PARTICIPATE. AND SO A
BROADER RANGE OF SURVEY DATA
AND MORE INFORMATION FROM
STUDENTS IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. WE ALSO NEED SOME
DISAGGREGATED DATA THERE'S A
TENDENCY TO LUMP A LOT OF
GROUPS TOGETHER OUR API FACULTY
OR STUDENTS FOR EXAMPLE ARE ALL
LUMPED INTO ONE CATEGORY. WE
NEED TO DISAGGREGATE THAT
INFORMATION- ALL OF THIS WILL
HELP TO IDENTIFY COLLEGES
DISTRICTS AND EVEN INDIVIDUAL
FACULTY THAT ARE DOING GOOD
WORK AND ENABLE US TO SHARE
THOSE PRACTICES. ESPECIALLY
WORK AROUND ENGAGING STUDENTS
MAKING CAMPUS MORE WELCOMING
WHETHER IT'S IN PERSON OR
ONLINE. ADDITIONALLY WE NEED TO
INCREASED PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR FACULTY ON HOW
TO ENGAGE STUDENTS BEST
PRACTICES FOR DOING SO AND
PEDAGOGICAL SUPPORT FOR THOSE
WHO CONTINUE TO TEACH ONLINE.
ALL OF THESE THINGS OF COURSE
REQUIRE FUNDING AS WELL AS
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT. THE
TRANSITION ONLINE WAS NOT EASY
IN SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY I AM
FROM DISTRICT WHICH PRIDES
ITSELF ON ITS ONLINE CLASSES
AND YET WE STRUGGLED- AND SO I
CAN'T IMAGINE CAMPUSES ARE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE VIRTUALLY
NO ONLINE PREVIOUSLY. I WORKED
CLOSELY WITH NURSING FACULTY-
WHICH IS QUITE AN EXCEPTIONAL
ACCOMPLISHMENT SINCE I AM
MYSELF A HISTORIAN AND TEACH
WOMEN'S STUDIES- BUT I WORKED
WITH THE NURSING FACULTY TO
WORK ON. A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
WEBINARS AND WAYS THAT THEY CAN
USE SIMULATION IN THEIR CLASSES
I LEARNED A LOT INCLUDING THAT
I'M NEVER GOING TO BE AN ALLIED
HEALTH FACULTY MEMBER. BECAUSE
I WAS TERRIFIED THAT THE FAKE
BABY WAS GOING TO DIE AND I
ALMOST BURST INTO TEARS DURING
ONE OF THE SIMULATIONS. NOT A
GOOD PLAYER. HOWEVER ONE OF THE
THINGS WE NOTICED WAS THAT THIS
WAS NOT A SYSTEMIC OR A
WIDESPREAD USE OF TOOLS. WE SAW
SOME CAMPUSES PROVIDE THEIR ALL
THEIR FACULTY WITH WIFI
HOTSPOTS WITH COMPUTERS WITH.
ALL KINDS OF THINGS OTHER
CAMPUSES DID NOT. WE
PARTICULARLY SOUGHT IN OUR
ADJUNCT AND PART TIME FACULTY
WHO STRUGGLED MANY OF WHOM HAVE
LOST CLASSES. C. AND REDUCED
THE SCENE REDUCED INCOMES. AND
ARE STRUGGLING TO MAINTAIN
THEIR STATUS ON OUR CAMPUSES-
DEPENDING ON THE COLLEGE CAMPUS
OR DISTRICT IN SOME CASES
ADDITIONAL FACULTY AND STAFF
WERE HIRED TO HELP FACULTY
TRANSITION. THERE WERE STIPENDS
PROVIDED AT SOME DISTRICTS.
SUPPORT SERVICES WERE ALSO SET
UP. BUT SYSTEMICALLY THE MAJOR
SOURCE OF HELP CAME FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. WITH THE
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE PURCHASED
WITH THEIR PURCHASING POWER. TO
ENABLE CLASSES TO TRANSLATE THE
SPECIALLY LAB CLASSES INTO AN
ONLINE FORMAT- THEY ALSO
ASSISTED WITH CHANGES IN
GRADING POLICIES. ARE EXTENDING
THE PERIOD DURING WHICH PASS NO
PASS COULD BE USED EXTENDING
THE PERIOD DURING WHICH EXCUSED
WITHDRAWAL COULD BE USED. AND
THAT PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS WHO OTHERWISE WOULD
HAVE STRUGGLED OR WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO COMPLETE
THEIR CLASSES. OR DECIDED THAT
THEY WANTED TO CONTINUE THE
CLASS BUT THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
RISK A VERY LOW GRADE- AND SO
THEY TO PASS NO PASS INSTEAD-
IN ADDITION ABOUT MY PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE AND I WILL SAY IT
DID MAKE ME MORE COMPASSIONATE
I THINK I'M MUCH NICER NOW
WHICH- I GUESS IS A GOOD THING-
I WAS MORE FLEXIBLE WITH
ASSESSMENTS I WAS MORE FLEXIBLE
WITH DUE DATES. MY COLLEGE
HAPPENS TO BE ON QUARTERS SO.
THEY'RE SUPER FAST ANYWAY AND
SO WHEN YOU THROW IN A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC- WE WERE FORTUNATE WE
WERE FINISHING OUR WINTER
QUARTER WHEN THE PANDEMIC IN
THE SHUTDOWN STARTED. AND SO WE
WERE ABLE TO TAKE AN EXTRA WEEK
OF SPRING BREAK TO PREPARING
FOR EVERYONE AND TO GET.
ACCLIMATED TO THE NEW
ENVIRONMENT- BUT I WILL SAY
THAT I HAD STUDENTS WHO
ACTUALLY STARTED REACHING OUT
TO ME AND I STARTED DOING A LOT
OF. ONLINE INVOLVEMENT WITH
ZOOM AND TALKING TO STUDENTS
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY WERE
OKAY AND- HEARING THEIR STORIES
AND- ONE OF MY STUDENTS REACH
OUT TO ME AFTER ABOUT THE THIRD
WEEK AND SAID I'M A MINUTE A
MINUTE COMPROMISED. I AM LIKELY
GOING TO HAVE TO DROP YOUR
CLASS BECAUSE I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO. NOT HAVE ANY CONTACT WITH
ANYTHING. ANYTHING AND SHE WAS
BRILLIANT SHE WAS THE BEST IN
THE CLASS AT THAT POINT. I
BEGGED HER TO STAY SHE SAID NOT
HAVE TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL I
CAN'T DO THIS I'M SORRY AND SHE
CAME BACK ABOUT TEN DAYS LATER
AND SAID. HEY THEY LET ME OUT
OF THE HOSPITAL I'M IN THE SAFE
ENVIRONMENT. CAN I JOIN YOUR
CLASS AGAIN AND I SAID THE
ABSOLUTELY YOU WERE DOING A
GREAT JOB I HAVE NO PROBLEM
WITH THIS AT ALL. SHE GOT THE
HIGHEST GRADE IN THE CLASS
SHE'S GOING TO STANFORD. SO
THOSE KINDS OF SUCCESSES ARE
WHAT KEEP US GOING- MY
COLLEAGUE ROBERT. A REFERENCE
TO THE EXHAUSTION WE'RE ALL
EXHAUSTED. EVERY FACULTY MEMBER
I SPEAK TO IS EXHAUSTED. WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY TIRED. MORE
INITIATIVES NOT THE WAY TO GO
AT THIS POINT. LET US JUST.
PLEASE TRY TO GET THROUGH ALL
THIS- BUT THERE ARE SOME
BARRIERS FOR US GOING BACK
CAMPUS. UP ALL I BELIEVE OF OUR
SEVENTY TWO DISTRICTS HAVE
CLASSES BACK ON CAMPUS AT THIS
POINT- AS DAVID O'BRIEN POINTED
OUT WE NEVER CLOSED- WE NEVER
SHUT DOWN COMPLETELY. OTHER
WERE SOME CAMPUSES WERE FACULTY
WERE BACK ON CAMPUS WITHIN
WEEKS OF THE INITIAL SHUTDOWN
TEACHING OUR CTE COURSES. OUR
FIRST RESPONDER COURSES AND THE
LIKE- BUT THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES A LOT OF THEM AROUND
WORKING CONDITIONS- AROUND MASK
MANDATES AROUND EXCEED
MANDATES- BUT- THERE ARE ALSO
ISSUES AROUND THINGS LIKE.
MATERIALS ON CAMPUS- IT'S
DIFFICULT TO TEACH SOME CLASSES
ONLINE THEY NEED TO BE TAUGHT
IN PERSON DO WE HAVE ENOUGH PP
FOR THE FACULTY TO TEACH- DO WE
HAVE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE
CAN MAKE- I REALLY APPRECIATED
THE QUESTION ABOUT DISABLED
STUDENTS- DORADO AND I ARE ON
THE STUDENTS HUNDRED LISTENING
TOUR WHICH IS TRAVELING TO
SEVEN COLLEGES THIS QUARTER.
SORRY THIS TERM CAN'T HELP BUT-
AND LISTENING TO STUDENTS ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THAT OUR
LAST TOUR WE HAD A- A MOTHER OF
A STUDENT WHO IS DISABLED
TALKING ABOUT HOW MUCH HAD BEEN
CLOSE TO THEM DURING THE
PANDEMIC IT WAS HEARTBREAKING-
AS SOMEONE WHO IS ENGAGED TO A
MAN WHO HAS MOBILITY ISSUES
WALKING AROUND A COUPLE OF THE
CAMPUSES HAS BEEN. A CLEAR
INDICATOR THAT THEY ARE NOT
DESIGNED FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
CRUMBLING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OTHER ISSUES HAVE MADE THEM
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT- FINALLY
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
RECOVERY WITH THE EQUITY. WE
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER WE CAN'T
PLACE BLAME ON ANY ONE GROUP OR
ANYONE SET OF PEOPLE FOR WHAT
HAS HAPPENED. THERE ARE SO MANY
VARIABLES AND CIRCUMSTANCES TO
CONSIDER. THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MOVE FORWARD ON
HOW TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
AND- THE NEEDS THAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM FACULTY AND
STUDENTS AND STAFF. ESPECIALLY
IN AREAS WHERE THERE MAY BE AN
INCREASE OF EQUITY GAPS- ALONG
WITH DIVERSITY CUT
DIVERSIFICATION OF THE FACULTY
AND THE STUDENTS ARE SYSTEM
COMES THE NEED. FOR A DIVERSITY
IN SOLUTIONS TO NAVIGATE
LEARNING AS WE MOVE FORWARD- WE
ALSO REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
MENTAL HEALTH POST PANDEMIC I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS ABOUT
THAT- OUR FACULTY AND STAFF
NEED THAT ESPECIALLY OUR
ADJUNCT FACULTY- WHO IN MANY
CASES AS I SAID BEFORE
STRUGGLING. AND FINALLY I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT IT'S BECOME
MORE CLEAR THAT SOLUTIONS
AROUND THIS NEED TO COME. FROM
THOSE WHO ARE CLOSEST TO THE
STUDENTS THAT IS THE
PRACTITIONERS ON THE CAMPUSES.
OF FACULTY STAFF ADMINISTRATORS
AND THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES-
THERE'S CLEARLY A NEED FOR MORE
COUNSELLING SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS THERE'S CLEARLY A NEED
FOR OTHER PIECES THE DORADO AND
I BOTH HEARD ABOUT- ALLOWING
STUDENTS TO STAY ON THEIR PATH
AND TRANSFERRING TO A FOUR YEAR
SYSTEM. GETTING A JOB SKILLS
BUILDING WHATEVER THEIR ECONET-
THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS ARE.
BUT GETTING STUDENTS IN AND OUT
AS IMPORT WHILE SOME GETTING
STUDENTS AND I WAS IMPORTANT.
FINDING OUT THEIR NEEDS AND
PROVIDING A PATHWAY TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS IS THE ABSOLUTE
DEFINITION OF A STUDENT
CENTERED SYSTEM AND ONE THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU DOORS AND NOW
WE WILL GO ON TO THAT ARE LOW
TRAVIS PRESIDENT STUDENT CENTER
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. I DID. LOSE MY MIND
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE- MY
NAME MR ARDAL CHAVEZ I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT CENTER
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THE STUDENT SENATE IS
UNIQUE IN THE SENSE THAT WE
REPRESENT ONE OF THE LARGEST
POPULATION. OF STUDENTS IN THE
NATION. OVER TWO POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS AND IT'S
REALLY HARD TO GAUGE STUDENT
INPUT- WHEN WE HAVE SUCH A VAST
DIVERSE. POPULATION BUT- THANK
GOODNESS THAT WE ARE TAUGHT TO
ME IN OUR STATE IS RE OPENING-
BECAUSE WE ARE VISITING OUR
STUDENTS. WERE COMING TO THEM.
ARE WE ARE LEADING THE SYSTEM
BY MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
CALLING TO THE STUDENTS AND THE
STUDENTS ARE NOT COMING TO US-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I DO
WANT TO ADDRESS IS THE IMPACT.
OF THE PANDEMIC TO OUR
STUDENTS. ARE FAR BEYOND SOCIAL
ECONOMIC IMPACTS ABOUT FOCUS ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR
STUDENTS. THE STUDENTS SENATE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY THAT
COLLECTED THE STORIES OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND A
COMMON THING THAT WE SEE IS-
THE EXHAUSTION OF THE MENTAL
EXHAUSTION IN THE EMOTIONAL
EXHAUSTION THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE IN DURING. IN THAT LEADS
TO. LEARNING LOSS ARE THAT THAT
LEADS INTO OUR DECLINE
ENROLLMENT BECAUSE MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS FEEL- HOPELESS. I HAVE
TO SAY THE LEAST THEY FEEL
HOPELESS BY CONTINUING. THIS IS
EDUCATION- IN THERE'S NO.
CONSENSUS ON DISTANCE EDUCATION
BECAUSE LIKE I SAID WE HAVE A-
DIVERSE POPULATION OF STUDENTS.
AND ONLINE EDUCATION HAS BEEN
HELPFUL FOR STUDENTS. ALTHOUGH
FOR SOME POPULATIONS IT HAS
BEEN IT HAS BECOME A BURDEN AND
HAS BECOME AN IMPEDIMENT TO
THEIR SUCCESS. IN WITHIN THOSE
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX-
STORIES THAT WE SAW. THERE'S
ONE STORY THAT- REALLY
HIGHLIGHTS HOW FAR CAN DEPEND
THAT MAY GO TO AFFECT OUR
STUDENTS. THERE WAS A STORY
THAT A STUDENT- SHE'S MARRIED-
IN DURING THE PANDEMIC. I SEE
HAD ANNOUNCED SAFE ENVIRONMENT
AT HOME- SHE EXPERIENCED ABUSE.
PHYSICAL. ABUSE FROM HER SPOUSE-
IS SHE SAID THAT SHE HAD NO ONE
TO TURN TO SO SHE BECAME
HOMELESS. THIS JUST PROVES THAT
ARE COLLEGES ARE MORE THAN- OF
THE CITIZENS OF LEARNING. I
COLLEGES HAVE BECOME A SECOND
HOME FOR STUDENTS THEY HAVE
BECOME IT'S THE SPACE FOR OUR
STUDENTS. AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EQUITY GAPS. EQUITY GAPS
HAVE BEEN THERE- YOU KNOW SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF OUR
INSTITUTION- BUT THE THING THAT
WE SEE IN THE PANDEMIC IS- ARE
YOU SEPARATE STUDENTS FROM THE
CAMPUS AND THAT IS WHERE WE
START SEEING THE HOUSING
SECURITY THE FOOD AND SECURITY.
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE ESPECIALLY
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE BECAUSE MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS RELIED ON OUR
CAMPUS FOR LIBRARIES ARE
WRITING CENTERS THE COMPUTERS
ARE ARE AVAILABLE ON CAMPUS.
AND WHEN WE WENT HOME BECAUSE
CAMPUS CLOSE IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY WE SAW HOW STUDENTS WERE
STRUGGLING AND WE SAW HOW
STUDENTS DID NOT HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY OR THE BROADBAND IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE WITH THEIR
EDUCATION. SO WHAT ARE ONE
THINGS THAT I SAW IS A LOT OF
STUDENTS SIMPLY JUST DROPPED
OUT- I LIVE IN THE L. EMPIRE
ENSURE YOU MAY KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF WAREHOUSES. IN
THE L. IMPAIRED- IN
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF MY PEERS
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES AND
FRIENDS. ARE DECIDED TO PUT
ASIDE THEIR MISSIONS- OF
PURSUING EDUCATION. AND WENT TO
THE WORK FORCE. ARE THEY
DROPPED OUT COMPLETELY AND WENT
TO THE WAREHOUSE- AMAZON
WAREHOUSES THAT WE HAVE IN THE-
EMPIRE- IN THOSE ARE SIMILAR
STORIES THAT WE SEE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- MANY OF STUDENTS
THAT- ONE OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS. DIED ONE OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS. BUY FOOD FOR THEIR
HOME FOR THEIR HOUSE ONLY MORE
SO THAT'S WHAT I HAVE TO PUT
AWAY THEIR AMBITION AND ENTER
THE WORKFORCE TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE ALSO SEE
WHAT THE PANDEMIC. IS THAT IS
THE FINE CLASSISM IN OUR
SYSTEM. UNDERLYING CLASSES AND
THAT WAS OFTEN IGNORED-
COMMITTEE CLOSE IS NO LONGER
JUST FOR EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS AND
TWENTY YEAR OLDS. WE SEE THIRTY
YEAR OLDS FORTY OR FIFTY YEAR
OLD EVEN SIX AND SEVEN YEAR
OLDS. AND WE SEE THEIR SYSTEM
WAS NOT DESIGNED FOR THEM. HOW
DO WE SEE THAT- LIKE I SAID
WE'VE BEEN VISITING CAMPUSES.
AND TO STUDENTS APPROACH ME AND
THEIR STUDENT PARENTS AND THEY
SAID. ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT I FACE AS A STUDENT
PARENT IS THAT'S HEALTHCARE.
ARTS HEALTHCARE HAS BECOME AN
IMPEDIMENT TO ACADEMIC SUCCESS-
JUST TO BE MORE SPECIFIC GOALS
TO STUDENTS THAT CHILD CARE
ENDS AT THREE PM. MY CLASSES
UNTIL FIVE PM. WHAT DO YOU DO
THEN- THEY SAID I HAD TO LEAVE
EARLY BECAUSE I HAVE TO BE
CLASS EARLY- AND THAT IS HOW WE
SEE THE EQUITY GAPS IN OUR
SYSTEM AND- HOW CAN WE ADDRESS
THAT. MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
LISTENING TO THE STUDENT
EXPERIENCE- WE HELP OVER TWO
POINT MILLION STUDENTS AND EACH
OF THEM HAS A UNIQUE EXPERIENCE
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO TELL YOU.
WHAT THE PREVENTIVE COSTS DOWN
FOR THEM. WHAT HOW THE HEALTH
OF CONDEMNING AFFECTED THEM-
BUT WE ALSO WOULD DEPEND THAT
MAKE WE HAVE SEEN INCREASE IN
ACCESSIBILITY. WE HAVE SEEN
THAT ARE FOR ADULT LEARNERS OR
STUDENTS WHO ARE GOING TO MY
CLASSES. WE HAVE SEEN AN
EXPANSION OF OURS FOR
COUNSELING- WE HAVE SEEN THAT.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND EDUCATION
HAS BECOME MORE ACCESSIBLE. AND
MORE CONVENIENT FOR STUDENTS-
THERE'S BEEN MULTIPLE ACCOUNTS
WHERE STUDENTS TELL ME THAT IT
WAS BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO RETURN TO
CAMPUS BECAUSE OF DISTANCE
LEARNING. OTHERWISE THEY WOULD
HAVE COME BACK TO COLLEGE OR
START THE ACADEMIC JOURNEY. SO
THAT'S A POSITIVE IMPACT THAT
WE HAVE SEEN. BUT REGARDLESS OF
THE NEGATIVE ALWAYS THE
POSITIVE UNFORTUNATELY. AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I DO WANT
TO- ADDRESS- SPECIALLY WITH-
WHAT WAS STUDENTS WHO ARE
TRANSFERRING- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE DID SEE AND OUR SURVEY.
IS THAT STUDENTS HOW TO DELAY.
THE TRANSFER PROCESS I
PERSONALLY HAVE TO DELAYED MY
TRANSFER- BECAUSE OF THE-
UNCERTAINTY WHETHER IN OTHER
THAT UNIVERSITY THAT I WAS
APPLYING WAS GOING TO RE OPEN.
IN MANY OF OUR STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE THE MEANS TO. WASTE MONEY-
SO WHY GO TO A FOUR YEAR- WHEN
I'M GOING TO WIN THIS DISTANCE
LEARNING WHEN I'M DOING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THAT'S WHAT
A LOT OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
THINKING- BUT OVERALL THE
PANDEMIC HAS REALLY SATELLITE
ON THE EQUITY GAPS. AND THE WAY
THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING THE
EQUITY GAPS IS PUTTING STUDENTS
UP FRONT. MAKING SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS AT THE TABLE WHEN
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THAT
ARTICLE AND I WILL GO TO
CHRISTIAN NOW HOW TRUE VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN DANA AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU ALL FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS KRISHAN
MALHOTRA I'M CURRENTLY A SENIOR
AT STANISLAUS STATE INTERLOCK
WHERE I STUDY BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION WITH A
CONCENTRATION IN MARKETING. I
ALSO SERVE AS THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. WHICH IS
THE OFFICIAL VOICE OF NEARLY
HALF A MILLION CSU STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. TODAY I'D
LIKE TO SHARE HOW CSU STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE MANAGED
TO DEAL WITH THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WHILE STILL TRYING TO
ACCESS THEIR EDUCATION AND
GRADUATE ON TIME. FIRSTLY WE
NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE FACED ALL OF THE
SAME CHALLENGES THAT YOU ALL
HAVE FACED HERE. WETHERBY
ISOLATION ILLNESS OR LOSS OF
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. STUDENTS
ALSO HAD MORE OF A UNIQUE
CHALLENGE WHERE WE HAD TO
STRUGGLE WITH THE TRANSITION TO
ONLINE LEARNING. THIS RESULTED
IN LEARNING LOSS AND
PERPETUATED EQUITY GAPS EVEN
MORE THAN WE COULD'VE IMAGINED
BEFORE. THE PANDEMIC HAS
EXACERBATED OTHER PRE EXISTING
ISSUES AS WELL LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH HOUSING AND FOOD
INSECURITY. NOBODY WAS PREPARED
FOR THIS PANDEMIC NOT THE STATE
NOT THE CSU AND DEFINITELY NOT
OUR STUDENTS. THIS LED TO A
HUGE SCRAMBLE IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
COULD TRANSITION TO BEING
VIRTUAL. AND IN THE BEGINNING
MOST OF THE EFFORTS WERE
CENTERED AROUND ENSURING
STUDENTS COULD ACCESS THEIR
CLASSES- WHILE THEY'RE ONLINE
AT HOME. CAMPUSES DID THEIR
BEST AT THE TIME TO ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE WEATHER WAS
PROVIDING HOT SPOTS ARE
CREATING PARTNERSHIP WITH BROAD
BAND- PROVIDERS TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS TO GAIN ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET. BUT EVEN WITH THOSE
EFFORTS STUDENTS STRUGGLED AND
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO THIS
DAY- WITH HAVING A STABLE AND
RELIABLE CONNECTION FOR THEIR
CLASSES. FOR THOSE WITHOUT A
LAPTOP CAMPUSES ALSO PROVIDED
LONERS- AND YOU KNOW THIS WAS
LIMITED TO THE AMOUNT OF
CAMPUSES- THE ABOUT A LAPTOP
THAT CAMPUS HAD- UNFORTUNATELY
LIKE YOU HEARD EARLIER WITH NEW
PROGRAMS LIKE C. SUCCESS.
FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER STUDENTS
ARE PROVIDED WITH A TABLET AND
KEYBOARD AND APPLE. PENCIL AND
SO STRIDES ARE BEING MADE TO
EXPAND THIS PROGRAM AND WE'RE
HOPING FOR MORE FUNDING. AND IT
CAN HELP US MOVE CLOSE EQUITY
GAPS MOVING FORWARD. AS YOU ALL
KNOW ALSO SITUATIONS VARY
GREATLY FROM CAMPUS TO CAMPUS
AND BUT GENERALLY THERE HAS
BEEN A LACK OF FEELING. OF
SUPPORT AND EMPATHY TO THE
STRUGGLES THAT OUR STUDENTS
HAVE FACED IN THE LAST TWENTY
ONE MONTHS. ASSUMPTIONS WERE
MADE THAT VIRTUAL LEARNING AND
ONLINE COURSES ARE EXACTLY THE
SAME AS THEY WOULD BE IN
PERSON. AND THAT'S THE FURTHEST
THING FROM THE TRUTH. VIRTUAL
LEARNING IS EXTREMELY DIFFERENT
AND EVEN TO THIS DAY OUR
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
BURNOUT ENGINE FATIGUE. THERE
ARE ALWAYS CHALLENGES AS WE ALL
KNOW VERY FIRST HAND BUT I FEEL
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE POSITIVE AS WELL.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES LIKE ACADEMIC
ADVISING IN MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELLING HAD MOVED TO AN
ONLINE AND NOW A HYBRID MODEL
SO STUDENTS COULD CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THOSE SERVICES. BECAUSE
OF THIS SHIFT MORE STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO USE THE SERVICES
WITHOUT HAVING TO TRAVEL TO
CAMPUS. WHICH IS GREAT AND
MAKES IT MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR US
ALL. STUDENTS ARE ALSO HAPPY TO
SEE THE CSU TEMPORARILY SUSPEND
THE ACT AND SAT AS EMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS TO ITS
UNIVERSITIES. AND HOPE THIS
BECOMES A PERMANENT- HOPE THIS
BECOMES PERMANENT AYE
STANDARDIZED TESTING POSES
DOWNSIDE OF EQUITY CONCERNS.
ANOTHER COMPONENT THAT STUDENTS
OF LIGHT IS THE FLEXIBILITY OF
ASYNCHRONOUS ONLINE COURSES.
THESE COURSES ALLOW FOR
STUDENTS TO LEARN ON THEIR OWN
AT THEIR OWN PACE- WHILE
BALANCING THEIR OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND STUDENTS
HAVE VOICED THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THIS MODEL BECAUSE IT MAKES A
DEGREE ACCESSIBLE TO THEM. JUST
BECAUSE THE TIMING AVAILABILITY.
NOW AS WE CONTINUE TO NAVIGATE
RETURNING TO CAMPUS STUDENTS
ARE TRYING TO NAVIGATE A WORLD
THE VACCINE REQUIREMENTS MASKS
AND THEIR OWN HEALTH CONCERNS.
WELL THE CSU DOES HAVE A
VACCINE MATTER- REQUIREMENT TO
LOWER THE RISK OF IN NINETEEN
TRANSITION- TRANSMISSION SORRY
SAFETY IS STILL A BIG CONCERN
FOR MANY OF OUR STUDENTS.
STUDENTS ARE FILLED STILL
FEELING THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND I STRUGGLING TO
NAVIGATE RETURNING TO CAMPUS
WHILE FINDING CHILD CARE.
TAKING CARE OF SICK FAMILY
MEMBERS AND A HUGE VARIANCE IN
GUIDELINES FROM CITY TO CITY
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. SOMETHING
AS SIMPLE AS PARKING AND
ALREADY INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE
SERVICE HAS HINDERED STUDENTS
ABILITY TO RETURN TO CAMPUS. SO
FAR ANSWER IS GOING BACK TO
CAMPUS WE NEED TO LOOK AT
WHAT'S HOLDING US BACK. THE
PANDEMIC ALSO RESULTED IN JOB
LOSS FOR COUNTLESS STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WHICH ONLY
EXACERBATED. PRE EXISTING
FINANCIAL STRUGGLES AND HINDER
THE STUDENTS ABILITY TO FOR
THEIR DEGREE. MOVING FORWARD
INCREASES AND REFORMS OF
FINANCIAL AID ARE CRITICAL TO
ENSURING STUDENTS CAN STILL
GRADUATE- AND THE EQUITY GAPS
ARE ELIMINATED. EMILY AND I
KNOW YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
SUPPORT FOR BASIC NEEDS IS ALSO
A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
RECOVERY AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE STATE CONTINUES TO
INVEST IN EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
FOOD INSECURITY HOMELESSNESS
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
INTERNET ACCESS AND TECHNOLOGY
WILL ALSO NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
THROUGH THE STATE TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS CAN BE SUCCESSFUL
IN FUTURE COURSES. REGARDLESS
OF WHAT MENTALITY THEY'RE BEING
TAUGHT IN. STUDENTS WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE TO SEE CHOICES AND
HOW AND WHERE THEY CAN ATTEND
CLASSES OR RECEIVE SERVICES.
HAVING OPTIONS- FOR STUDENTS TO
ATTEND EITHER IN PERSON OR
ONLINE ALLOWS A STUDENT TO HAVE
THE CHOICE TO DETERMINE WHAT IS
BEST FOR THEIR LEARNING STYLE
WHILE ALSO CONSIDERING THEIR
OTHER OBLIGATIONS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. IN CONCLUSION
OUR STATE NEEDS TO INVEST IN
OUR STUDENTS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS EXIST IN
ORDER TO BETTER THE LIVES OF
STUDENTS. RIGHT NOW WE'RE
STRUGGLING. THIS STATE OUR
INSTITUTIONS MUST WORK TOGETHER
TO MITIGATE THE HORRIBLE IMPACT
THE PANDEMIC HAS HAD AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN DO THAT TOGETHER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
CHRISTIAN. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
STEVE DORSEY THE THIRD
PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION OF LOS HERE
UNIVERSITY. ALL RIGHTS TO
EXPRESS THE HELLO THERE YOU GO.
ODD TO THE DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS LAWRENCE STEPHEN DORSEY
THE THIRD A GRADUATING SENIOR
AND STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT FROM
LAST YEAR UNIVERSITY- FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ALL THE SIMPLY OF HIGHER
EDUCATION MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS DISCUSSION ON BEHALF OF
LAST YEAR UNIVERSITY- THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY I DO NOT TAKE
FOR GRANTED. ANIMAL HONORED
THAT. I THINK THAT WE AS
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENTS CAN
AGREE THAT THIS IS ADVOCACY AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL- FOR THE
STUDENTS WE'VE BEEN TASKED
REPRESENTS- ALL HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT THOUSAND IN OUR SECTOR TO
BE EXACT. THIS IS WHAT PROGRESS
LOOKS LIKE. I WANT CONSTRUCTING
MY TESTIMONY- THERE ARE MANY
SUBJECTS I WANTED TO SHED LIGHT
ON. A YET IN ORDER TO DO SO I
HAD TO BE HONEST WITH MYSELF.
AND WE NEED TO BE HONEST WITH
OURSELVES. I WHEN WE ALLOCATE
THE BLAME OF LEARNING LOSS AND
EQUITY CHASMS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION HOLY. TO THE
PANDEMIC. WE AS INSTITUTIONS
AND INDIVIDUALS HIDE OUR GAZE
FROM THE STARK REALITY WE MUST
ADMIT TO OURSELVES. THE
PANDEMIC ONLY HIGHLIGHTED AND
EXAGGERATED ALREADY VISCERAL
DISPARITIES PRESENT IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. FIVE FOR BEING TRULY
HONEST WITH OURSELVES EVERY
UNIVERSITY PRESENT HERE TODAY
KNOWS WE HAVE A FRAGMENT OF
BLAME TO SHARE FOR THIS FACT.
KOPEN NINETEEN BECAUSE THIS ALL
ITS INSTITUTIONS TO IMPARTIALLY
LOOK AT OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
AND ASK ARE WE GIVING EVERYONE
A FAIR CHANCE- THIS IS A
DIFFICULT QUESTION TO PONDER
WHICH MAKES IT ALL THE MORE
IMPERATIVE- TO CULTIVATE
EDUCATION SYSTEMS OF TRUE
EQUITY. THE CHALLENGE OF
LEARNING DURING THE PANDEMIC
WAS HAVING THE PRESENCE OF MIND
TO LEARN- MISS SOCIAL UPHEAVAL
AND TAKING ON ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES. I STUDENTS WE
WERE ATTENDING CLASSES WITH
UNEXPLAINABLE AMOUNTS OF
COGNITIVE SHRAPNEL CAUSED BY
SOCIETY AND NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO ONLINE LEARNING-
WHILE WE HAD TO ADJUST OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM FAILED AT
TIMES TO JUST WITH US. SOME
STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO THRIVE
DURING THE ONLINE ERROR OF
SCHOOLING- MAINTAIN A STEADY
SCHEDULE EVEN INCREASE THEIR
GPA. HOWEVER FAR TOO MANY
STUDENTS SPOKE OF WORKING FORTY
HOUR WEEKS. BABYSITTING AND
LONG ON TO ZOOM ONLY FOR THE
COURSE MATERIAL TO GO OVER
THEIR HEADS. NOW BY NO MEANS IN
MY SIGNING THE BLAME- TO
ADMINISTRATORS OR PROFESSORS
FOR THIS CAUSALITY I NEVER THE
LESS I BIGGEST ALL TO LOOK
COMPREHENSIVELY AT THAT JARRING
CONTRAST- ANECDOTES ASIDE ASIDE
DATA WOULD SUGGEST THAT
STUDENTS LOGGING FORTY HOUR
WEEKS AND- IN ADDITION TO
EIGHTEEN CREDIT. CLASSES WERE
PRIMARILY PERSONS OF COLOR. I'M
MORE ALREADY KNEE DEEP IN
STUDENT LOANS. STUDENTS WHO
MADE THEIR WAY INTO HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS- BY SHEER
FORCE OF WILL ONLY FOR THE RUG
TO BE PULLED UP ANYTHING. THE
MOST TROUBLING ASPECT OF THIS
PROBLEM LIES IN THE FACT THAT
EVEN BEFORE COVER NINETEEN THE
STUDENTS HAD THEIR BACKS TO THE
WALL FINANCIALLY. OF THE
PANDEMIC FORCE THESE DARK SHOES
INTO THE OPEN. HOWEVER THERE
STOOD A BRILLIANT FEW- WHO
ACTED AS A LIGHT BEARS IN THIS
DARKNESS THOSE WHO WISH TO SEE
STUDENTS SUCCEED REGARDLESS OF
SOCIETAL CIRCUMSTANCE AND
ADJUSTED ACCORDINGLY.
PROFESSORS FACULTY AND STAFF
WHO STOOD IN THE GAP FOR
STUDENTS WHEN THEY COULD NOT
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES. AT TIMES
NUMEROUS PROFESSORS SHIFTED
THEIR ENTIRE LESSON PLANS AND
LEARNING OUTCOMES TO FACILITATE
A LEARNING EXPERIENCE-
CONDUCIVE TO STUDENT SUCCESS.
WEATHER WAS INCORPORATING-
EXPERIENCE- WHETHER IT WAS
INCORPORATING MORE ASYNCHRONOUS
CLASSES GIVING STUDENTS THE
ABILITY TO GO AHEAD OR
EXTENDING GRACE TO STUDENTS
WITH LIFE ALTERING-
CIRCUMSTANCES ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL. THESE INDIVIDUALS GAVE
HOPE WHEN IT WAS IN LOW SUPPLY.
ON A UNIVERSITY LEVEL I CAN
SPEAK PERSONALLY TO- LAST YEAR
AS WELLNESS DEPARTMENT REMOVING
THE LIMIT OF COUNSELING
SESSIONS ACCESSIBLE TO STUDENTS
AND TRANSITIONING THE ENTIRE
DEPARTMENT ONLINE IN ORDER TO
MEET THE READILY APPARENT NEED
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT.
DECISIONS LIKE BEES MADE THE
TRANSITION TO ONLINE LEARNING
EASIER WHEN EVERYTHING IN THE
WORLD SUGGESTED DESPAIR WAS THE
ONLY AVAILABLE OPTION. MY
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS MATTER IS
ONE I'LL CARRY WITH ME TO ALL
MY FUTURE ENDEAVORS- BECAUSE
BEFORE THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC I SERVED AS A
RESIDENTIAL ASSISTANT IN THE
DORM. AND DURING THE RISE-
DURING THE PANDEMIC I SERVED AS
A STUDENT DEAN FOR THE
RESIDENCE HALL- AS AN RA I WAS
PART OF THE TEAM THAT
FACILITATED THE MASSIE
TRANSITION IN CLEARING OUT THE
DORMS. IN LESS THAN A WEEK-
THERE WAS AN INHERENTLY
HARROWING NATURE TO TELLING
STUDENTS TO PACK THEIR
BELONGINGS. AND NOT BEING ABLE
TO CONFIDENTLY TELL THEM WHEN
THEY BE BACK- I REMEMBER
CONSOLING INTERNATIONAL
RESIDENTS WHO WERE UNSURE WHEN
THEY WOULD SEE THEIR FAMILIES
AGAIN- DUE TO TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS. I REMEMBER
REASSURING STUDENTS WITH
UNHEALTHY LIVING ENVIRONMENTS
AT HOME THAT THEY WOULD
PREVAIL. THAT WE WOULD SEE EACH
OTHER AGAIN- AS A STUDENT IN
YOUR ONE OF THE PANDEMIC I
RECALL COUNTLESS PEERS TELLING
ME THEY CAN'T AFFORD COLLEGE
ANYMORE DUE TO THEM HAVING TO
PICK UP MORE WORK SINCE THEIR
PARENT WAS LAID OFF. ALL THIS
BEING SAID- MY PERSPECTIVE
DURING THE PANDEMIC ALSO
GRANTED ME INSIGHT. INTO THE
INGENUITY AND RESILIENCE OF THE
MODERN STANDARD. I SAW STUDENTS
FIND THEIR VOICE APPEARS TO
REALIZE THAT THEIR VOICES CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE WHEN JOINED
TOGETHER. OF THE PANDEMIC
SHOWED ME A GLIMPSE OF HOPE FOR
WHAT MY GENERATION CAN AND WILL
ACCOMPLISH IF WE STAY THE
COURSE. THE PANDEMIC SHOWED US
ALL THAT WE HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO BE RADICALLY INTENTIONAL IN
CHANGING SYSTEMS IF. WE ALLOW
OURSELVES TO THINK BEYOND
CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCE. MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY THAT IN ITSELF
IS THE IS THE KEY TO CLOSING
THE EQUITY GAP IN EDUCATION-
ALLOWING OURSELVES TO FATHOM
THE POSSIBILITY OF CHANGE. I
CAN ALWAYS THIS IS NOT AN EASY
TASK- BUT IT IS A NECESSARY ONE.
IF WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
IN THE SAME WAY WE WILL YIELD
THE SAME EXACT RESULTS. ARE
RECOVERY AND RESTORATION WILL
REQUIRE RE EXAMINATION AND
AUTHENTIC ANALYSIS OF
UNIVERSITY POLICY AND WHOM IT
MAY ADVERSELY AFFECT. SHUTTING
THE DOOR TO PANDEMIC INEQUALITY
IN EDUCATION WILL REQUIRE
MONUMENTAL STEPS LIKE EXTENDING
THE PASS OR FAIL OPTION ON
GREAT BOOKS OR FOR GOING THE S.
A. T. AT ACT FOR INCOMING
FRESHMEN- WHICH ARE EXCELLENT
STEPS IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
RECOVERY WILL REQUIRE TIME. IT
WILL DEMAND COMMITMENT BUT MOST
OF ALL IT WILL TAKE PEOPLE LIKE
YOU PRESENT HERE TODAY WILLING
TO CONTINUE THE FIGHT- WE OWE
IT TO GENERATIONS PAST AND WE
MUST BE BETTER FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU LAWRENCE- DR
WEBER THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
J. DR CHOI QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WILL. NOT A PARTICULAR
QUESTION I APPRECIATE THE FULL
COMING UP BUT THE TESTIFIED AND
I KNOW ALL COMING UP IS NOT
THAT EASY BUT- I ALSO MADE THE
TRIP FROM ORANGE COUNTY THIS
MORNING I GOTTA CATCH MY PLANE
PRETTY SOON. ABOUT THE I DO
KNOW THAT A LOT OF- ISSUES-
COME UP- ON THE CAMPUS- A
PARTICULARLY IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- I HAVE TALKED TO MY
CELL PHONE AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO FOR SEVENTY NEAR
SAYS THAT JUMPED FACULTY SO I
KNOW IT'S JUGGLING THE-
CONTAMINATED EIFFEL BECAUSE
MOST OF MOST OF THE STUDENTS
SO. THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- FROM MAJORITY
MAJORITY OUR ADULT POPULATION
AND THEN ALSO ATTENDING THE
CLASSES SO BUT THE- I'VE BEEN
I'VE BEEN THINKING. SOME STILL
SOME UNIVERSITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN OPERATING- ESPECIALLY
AFTER HIGHER LEARNING EDUCATION
ON ON OUR WAY BEFORE. THIS
FUNDAMENTAL. I IN MOST PART IF
NOT ELEMENTARY LEVEL LONG
ENOUGH- I'M NOT LOADING AND-
USED TO THE ONLINE LEARNING.
AND THERE IS PRESSURE ON THE
PLAN- ONE OF YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE ONE NINE LOOTING FOR MYSELF
LESS ABILITY AND I DON'T HOLD
YOUR OWN PAYS OUT AND TAKING
CARE OF ALL. IN ALL HOUSE
CHORES AND THEIR CHILDREN AND
WHEN YOU HAVE TIME AT THE
EVENING TIMES YOU CAN OPEN UP A
CAN MONNING STILL NOT WELL
ATTENDED TO SAY EVEN THOUGHT
THERE ARE SOME. OF THE PROBLEMS.
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT THE- I'VE
BEEN THINKING. IF IN THE FUTURE
IF WE CAN- BUT VALUES TO
TECHNOLOGY. AND MANY MINUS. THE
DIFFICULTIES OF ONLINE LEARNING.
AMADOR SAID IMPROVE WHAT THE
TECHNOLOGY- FOR ONLINE LEARNING.
AND NOT. TOTALLY ELIMINATE THE
COLLEGE CAMPUSES DO YOU THINK
OF AS A PHYSICAL IDEA. WELL LET
THE STUDENT CENTER THAT WOULD
BE I THINK THAT'S A GOOD A
GREAT POINT VICE CHAIR TO AYE
AYE I'M JOHN I'M NOT SURE THAT
THAT WOULD WORK FOR ALL OF OUR
MAJORS AND PROGRAMS THOUGH- I
THINK THE BENEFIT OF ONLINE
LEARNING IS THAT IT PROVIDES
THE FLEXIBILITY. TO THE PEOPLE
WHOSE LEARNING STYLE THAT
ONLINE LEARNING- MEETS. HOWEVER
THERE ARE CERTAIN STUDENTS WHO
HAVE A HARD TIME LEARNING IF
THEY'RE NOT IN THE CLASSROOM
AND I'VE SEEN ON MY CAMPUS I
WALKED AROUND SOME OF THE
BUILDINGS AND THERE'S A LIFE
SIZE DUMMIES AND DOLLS OF FOR
NURSING PROGRAMS THAT. THEY
TERRIFY ME BUT THEY NEED THAT
PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE- ONCE THEY
GO TO THE HOSPITAL OR TO THE
FACILITY TO WORK SO. I THINK
FOR THE STUDENTS THAT WORKS FOR
WE SHOULD LET IT WORK FOR THEM
AND FOR THE REST OF US AND THEN
FOR THE REST OF THE OTHER
STUDENTS THEY SHOULD HAVE THAT
SPACE TO RETURN TO CAMPUS
WHETHER THAT'S NOW OR-
EVENTUALLY. IN ONE EXAMPLE I
THOUGHT THE- ONLY ONE OF THE
MORE DIFFICULT TO STUDY IS SO-
THE- OF THE DISCIPLINE OF
THROUGH ONLINE LEARNING WITH
THE NURSING BECAUSE A
NOURISHING ORDER ORDER HAVE TO
SHOW DEMONSTRATE THAT OFF IN A
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE BODY AND
THE HOW TO INTERACT WITH THE
PATIENTS OR WHATEVER.
SURPRISINGLY ENOUGH- MY- OUR
DAUGHTER IN ALL. HAS BEEN
ENROLLED IN ONE CLASS AT
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA. IN
NOURISHING AND THE NEXT MONTH
SUCH AS CAN I GET THE DOCTORATE
DEGREE IN NURSING-
PRACTITIONERS- DISCIPLINE AND
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
CONGRATULATE. AND THAT DOESN'T
ACCEPT FOR IF A NURSING CAN BE.
ARCHTOP ONLINE HOW COME THEY
DON'T REST OF THE- SUBJECTS I'M
SURE THAT THE SOMETHING
SOMETHING CLASS TO SOME.
INVOLVE OUR LAB WORK ETCETERA
SO. I THINK THAT THAT CAN
SOFTEN MASTABA ISSUES HAS TO
ADDRESS US SUBJECT TO I GUESS
UP EDUCATIONAL EXPERT EXPLOSIVE
TO RESEARCH AND EXPERIMENT
EXPERIMENT THE WEATHER THAT
WILL PROVIDE THE MORE
CONVENIENT SELF ASSURANCE UP TO
LEARN. AND IS A STRONGER TO
PARKER THEY'LL PAY PARKING FEES
AND THE CHILD CARE BY A- ON A
FULL IN PERSON RUNNING ON
CAMPUS HAS A LOT OF A DRAWBACK
TO SO I THINK THAT'S THE ONE
AREA I'M THINKING WE CAN WE
SHOULD EXPLORE. THAT'S A JUST A
COMMENT. IF MAY MATCH IT IF I
COULD ADD A DO ALSO BELIEVE IT
IS A- INSTANCE OF BOTH AND IT
REALLY DOESN'T HAVE TO BE-
EITHER OR BECAUSE THERE ARE
THOSE WONDERFUL STORIES OF
PROGRAMS BEING ABLE TO ADJUST
AND STILL BE AFFECTED IN THEIR
LEARNING OUTCOMES- HOWEVER
THERE ARE. YOU KNOW ON THE FLIP
SIDE SO FOR INSTANCE LAST YEAR
I WAS DOING MY RESEARCH
SEQUENCE FOR MY METHODS AND
RESEARCH STATISTICS COURSE. AND
IT WAS REALLY DIFFICULT TO DO A
STUDY ONLINE- ONLY BECAUSE YOU
MISS OUT ON SO MUCH IN PERSON
RECRUITING- HOWEVER. WE WERE
ABLE TO PUT THE SURVEY ONLINE
AND RECRUIT THROUGH THAT AND WE
GOT A DECENT AMOUNT OF
PARTICIPANTS SO. I THINK WE
SHOULD AND CAN KEEP BOTH
SYSTEMS AND THEY CAN STILL BE
EFFECTIVE AND WE SHOULD. BUT
THAT THAT WOULD BE MY TAKE ON
IT THANK YOU. WITH THAT I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE PRESENTERS AND
I HOPE I WILL. HAVE TIME FOR.
AB ONE OR TWO- QUESTIONS FROM
THE PUBLIC. IF THERE'S ANYONE
OUT THERE WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS.
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
AND IF YOU WOULD- IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. AND- AND PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF I THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN DANA AND DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON DR DAVID
CARLISLE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
CHARLES R. DREW UNIVERSITY OF
MEDICINE AND SCIENCE INCLUDING
NURSING AND LOS ANGELES I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE
YOU. I'M ARE UNIVERSITY- TOOK
90% OF OUR INSTRUCTION OFF
CAMPUS DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
SENSE RETURNED TO INSTRUCTION
FULLY REOPEN OUR CAMPUS TO THE
USE OF A VACCINE MANDATE-
SCREENING TEST PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES SUCH AS REQUIRING
FACEMASKS AND- HANDWASHING AT
CETERA. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ARTICULATE AND ARE ENGAGE OUR
COMMUNITY THROUGH A VARIETY OF
EVENTS NOT JUST EDUCATIONAL.
BUT BY DOING OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND COVERT NINETEEN
DIAGNOSTIC TEST IN OUR
COMMUNITY. PROVIDING CAMPUS AND
COMMUNITY FORUMS- PARTICIPATING
AND WEBER. AND ON TELEVISION
MEDIA- DOING VACCINATION
CLINICS. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT WE ARE VERY PROUD TO
CONTINUE OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AT
THE STATE PROVIDED OR PART
PRIVATE UNIVERSITY PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE OPENING OF OUR FOR YOUR
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM AGAIN
WITH A FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT- RESIDENTS OFOUR
UNDERSERVED NOT A RESOURCE
COMMUNITY CAN CONTINUE TO
PRODUCE THE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE NEED
GOING FORWARD ESPECIALLY IN THE
FACE OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE PUBLIC IF SO PLEASE
APPROACH HE MICROPHONE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN- MEDINA AND
JIM SHERMAN PERSONS USING MY
NAME IS RELAUNCH AND I'M A MOM
AND ALSO I WAS A HOME SCHOOL
TEACHER. TO SUCCEED IN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT AND SUCCESS OF
THEIR STUDENTS YOU MUST PROVIDE
SCHOOL CHOICE. NO CHILD SHOULD
BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST WITH A
VACCINATED PARTIALLY VACCINATED
OR NOT OXYGENATED. WITH THE
ERROR OF CULTURE RACE ETHNIC
COLOR CREED AGE SEX GENDER
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH. OR LANGUAGE BARRIERS
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE A SAFE
FREE OF HARASSMENT NON
JUDGMENTAL- AND I'M POLITICAL
AGENDA- INSTITUTIONS THEY HAVE
ENOUGH TO WORRY ABOUT. AND I'VE
STRUGGLED. I NEVER SAW ANOTHER
STRUGGLES WHERE WE PUSHING A
PER CHILD IS THIS CORRECT
PRONOUNS WHEN ADDRESSING ADULT
OR ANOTHER CHILD WHY DON'T WE
JUST TEACH NAMES. WE NEED TO
STOP PROJECTING OUR FEARS UPON
THEM WE'RE COMING INTO. POST
CODE NOW THIS IS. LIVING ON TO
POST CODE. I HOPE YOU GUYS
REALIZE THAT. ALL OF YOU. WE
HAVE SO MUCH TECHNOLOGY COUNT
WE HAVE SO MUCH INFORMATION ON
AND WE REALLY REALLY NEED TO
FALL THE SCIENCE AND LISTEN TO
SCIENCE ALL FINANCES. WE NEED
TO STOP PROTECTING OUR FEARS
UPON THEM. GETTING BETTER
CHILDREN WERE COMING INTO- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE WE HAVE MUCH
BIGGER ISSUES WE'RE FACING NOW.
WITH OUR CHILDREN AND I THINK
WE REALLY NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
TO SOLVE THESE ISSUES- IF YOU
WANT TO STOP AND INEQUALITIES
DISPARITIES. AND GAIN EQUITIES.
START WORKING TOGETHER ALL THE
REST. AND COULD YOU KNOW THE
PARENTS IN YOUR EDUCATIONAL
DECISIONS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
STRONG VOICE HERE WE NEED TO BE
HEARD. WE KNOW OUR CHILDREN
PASSED. HECK WE WORKED OUR ****
WE CARRIED A SPECIALLY AS
MOTHERS WE CARRIED THEM INTO
ROOMS FOR NOW I TEN MONTHS. WE
KNOW OUR CHILDREN BY SO WE KNOW
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEM. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. WE HAVE TO
HAVE MORE SKEWS ME WE HAVE TO
HAVE MORE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THIS. AND STOP LIVING IN FEAR
THE SHOWS IN OUR CHILDREN DOES
IT NOT. LOOK AT THEIR
STATISTICS LOOK AT THE REPORT.
THEY'VE ALL SUFFERED THIS LAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. OKAY AND I
KNOW THAT OTHERS HAVE SUFFERED.
OTHERS HAVE SUFFERED BEFORE
THIS. LET'S EVER GOING TO BE
HONEST WITH BRING IT ALL TO THE
TABLE. ALL OF US. OKAY I DON'T
LIKE THIS THIS A MINUTE IN A
MINUTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION I APPRECIATE
THAT AND THANK YOU FOR GIVING
ME THE TIME THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S WORK TOGETHER EVERYBODY
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO NOW TO
MAYBE A COUPLE OF CALLS ON THE
PHONE LINE IF WE HAVE ANY ON
THE PHONE LINE SIR. AT&T
MODERATOR. YES LEGAL JUDGMENT
ON THE PHONE LINES HE'D LIKE TO
WRITE COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. SO BE JUST A
MOMENT- WELL WE GET THAT
QUESTION.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY ONE- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN IAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON HIS MENU
RODRIGUEZ FROM THE EDUCATION
TRUST WEST FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TO LEARN ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN YOUR TO A CO THE
PANDEMIC ARE HIGHER AND CHECK
WHAT'S THE COVER NINETY
PANDEMIC HAS AMPLIFIED THE NEED
OF STUDENTS ALREADY
MARGINALIZED WELL BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. THE PANDEMIC RESULTED
IN CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES BEING JOLTED INTO
DRASTICALLY CHANGING COURSE TO
MEET STUDENTS BASIC MENTAL AN
ACADEMIC NEEDS BY CENTERING
STUDENTS IN NEW AND INNOVATIVE
WAYS. AS WE HEARD ON THE FRONT
END OF THE PANELS. AND HOW DID
YOU LEADERS CLASS STUDENTS
RETURN TO COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AROUND THE STATE
THEY HAVE A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO SUSTAIN THE RESPONSIVE AND
INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO
SUPPORTING STUDENTS. ESPECIALLY
AS THEY RECEIVE HISTORIC AMOUNT
OF FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING
DURING THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET YEAR. OUR ADDRESS
WEST OF THESE INVOICES THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
BRIEF OUTLINE EIGHT SETS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS GROUNDED
INVOICES FROM THE FIELD THE
HIGHER EDUCATION LEADERS SHOULD
IMPLEMENT. THAT SUMMER STUDENTS
AND MAKE THEIR CAMPUSES MORE
EQUITABLE I DO RETURN TO IN
PERSON. DOES RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND KEEPING RACIAL EQUITY
FRONT AND CENTER. MEETING
STUDENT HEALTH AND WELLNESS
NEEDS. ADDRESSING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE PROVIDING STUDENT
SERVICES BY MAINTAINING
FLEXIBLE HYBRID OPPORTUNITIES
AND FOSTERING COMMUNITY BY
BUILDING A PERSONAL CONNECTION
WITH THE SPORTS TEAMS.
RETAINING AND RE ENGAGING
STUDENTS. LIKE YOU DID AND YOU
THAT MAKE DAY CONGRESS. AND
COMMUNICATION ALL HIRED STATE-
WE'D BE HAPPY TO CONNECT WITH
ANY OF YOUR OFFICERS TO GO OVER
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS OR TALK
ABOUT HOW THE ALREADY HAPPENING
IN THE FIELD AND EXPLORE WAYS
ON HOW THEY CAN BE SCALED UP-
WE WILL BE A RESOURCE FOR
ANYTHING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. ATG MODERATOR THERE
YES WE DO HAVE ANOTHER ONE IN
OUR QUEUE- WILL GO TO NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO. THE GOOD. HI IS
THIS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
I'M IN THE RIGHT PLACE- IS THIS
THE EDUCATION HEARINGS IS THE
COMMITTEE- BECAUSE- EXCELLENT
BECAUSE THIS MORNING IN THE
COURT HEARING AFTER WAITING FOR
FOUR HOURS THERE WAS NO PUBLIC
COMMENT TAKEN. SO JUST IN THE
SPIRIT O THE BAGLEY KEENE OPEN
MEETINGS LAW I WAS JUST HOPING
THAT THAT WOULD NOT BE THE SAME
OUTCOME THIS AFTERNOON. SO THAT
BEING SAID I APPRECIATE YOU-
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENTS. AND I
WANT TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT- THIS ISSUE OF COMPULSORY
MEDICINE- THE NATIONWIDE AND
EVEN GLOBAL PUSH WERE COMPELLED
VACCINATIONS WHICH INCLUDES
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION APPARENTLY
HEARD THE COMMENTS AND MANDATES
BY- GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM INMY
PERSPECTIVE IS UNLIKELY THE
DEFINING ISSUE OF OUR TIME. IF
WE ALLOW GOVERNMENTS TO CONTROL
WHAT GOES INTO OURS AND OUR
CHILDREN'S BLOOD STREAMS MISTER
MISTER EIGHTY TWO MODERATOR IF
WE COULD LEAD TO ANOTHER
COMMENT ONCE. HI AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU THIS
RUNNER- I WANT TO THANK AGAIN
ALL THE PRESENTERS ARE FOR
BEING HERE I THINK IT IS BEEN-
FRUITFUL- SESSION- I HEARD BOTH
THE CHALLEGES AND- THE GOOD
POINTS. OF THE EXPERIENCE OVER
THE LAST- YEAR AND A HALF TWO
YEARS OF INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
LEARNING- WITH DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AND BUT WHAT YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE TAKEAWAYS I'VE HEARD
HOW AND I THANK THE STUDENTS
FOR THEIR TENACITY FOR THEIR
STAND WITH IT BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS I DID HERE WAS- THE NEED
FOR PERSONAL INTERACTION
BETWEEN STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
THE EXPERIENCE OF COLLEGE BEING
MORE THAN JUST THE CLASSROOM
MORE THAN JUST WHAT HAPPENS
DURING THE ONE HOUR HOUR AND A
HALF OF LECTURE. YOU KNOW THAT
THEIR COLLEGE EXPERIENCE AT ALL
LEVELS IS BEING THERE. BEING
THERE IN PERSON AND SO FOR THAT
I'M VERY. GRATEFUL THAT WE ARE
MOVING BEYOND WHERE WE WERE A
YEAR AND A HALF TWO YEARS AGO.
I THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PRESENTATIONS THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AND WITH THAT THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
IS A DIRECT. THANK YOU